WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE JOINT
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON THE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE UP.
HOUSING EGGMAN OF ELEMENT
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
COMMITTEE ON THE TOPIC OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HOUSING
PACKAGE.
I'LL LET ME FIRST JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK.
BOTH OUR COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
HERE AS WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ENGAGED LAST YEAR.
WITH OUR GOVERNOR PASSING A
HISTORIC PACKAGE OF FIFTEEN
HOUSING BILLS THAT INCLUDED
FUNDING REGULATORY REFORM AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN ENFORCEMENT
MEASURES TO ADDRESS.
THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT OUR
STATE IS IN.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
IS TO GET AN UPDATE ON THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE BY.
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
DEPARTMENT AND AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT LAST YEAR'S HOUSING
PACKAGE TO GET FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS ON SOME KEY ASPECTS
OF THE PACKAGE AND GET INPUT
FROM EXPERTS ON WHAT WE NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT NEXT.
AS MANY OF US SAID LAST YEAROF
DIE HOUSING PACKAGE OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHILE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FORWARD WAS A
DOWN PAYMENT ON A PROBLEM THAT
HAS BEEN GROWING FOR DECADES IT
WILL TAKE US YEARS TO GET OUT
OF.
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM DONE BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT AS WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON NEW SOLUTIONS.
WE ENSURE THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION A PREVIOUS
EFFORTS AND THAT BEING SAID. I
WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO.
MY COUNTERPART IN THE SENATE
CENTER BELT FOR HIS OPENING
COMMENTS.
I LIKE.
THANK CHAIRMAN CHIU AND.
.
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
FOR.
CO HOSTING THIS EVENT WITH.
MY COMMITTEE WHICH I CHAIR
WHICH IS THE.
SENATE TRANSPORTATION AND
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
FOR THIS JOINT HEARING WE HAD A
BUSY YEAR LAST YEAR OF. IN
SACRAMENTO INTO THE.
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST PROBLEMS
LED ON MY DOES.
OF COURSE A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND.
.
THE CRUMBLING TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE SO.
WE WERE VERY PLEASED TO.
.
HAVE.
THE HOUSING PACKWOOD SHE WHICH
INCLUDED.
DUH.
SEVERAL BILLS INCLUDING.
.
S. B. TWO.
BY OUR INCOMING PRESIDENT PRO
TEM.
TONI ATKINS IN MY AND MY BILL S.
B. THREE WHICH IS THE HOUSING
BONDS.
ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT.
AND.
.
WE TOGETHER THESE TWO BILLS WERE
CREATED AN ESTIMATED SEVENTY
THOUSAND HOMES.
IN TERMS OF.
THE BASIC RESULT WHICH WILL ON
AVERAGE SERVE FIVE LOWER INCOME
FAN.
SERVE THE LOWER INCOME FAMILIES
OVER THEIR LIFE ON THAT LIKE
TIME.
SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
.
HAVING THAT AND THE THIRTEEN
OTHER BILLS.
CREATED LONG TERM OR SHORT TERM
INVESTMENTS ALLOWS REGULATION
REFORM.
WHICH WAS IMPORTANT.
TO SPEED UP NEW HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION.
AND I'M ALSO ACUTELY AWARE
DESPITE OUR COLLECTIVE HARD WORK
LAST YEAR.
WE HAVE NOT.
FINISH THE JOB.
AND.
THE LEGISLATURE MUST CONTINUE
TO INSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
HAS A.
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE THIS MEANS WORKING ON.
INSURING NO PERSON EXPERIENCES
ARE FACE
HOMELESSNESS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM OUR DISTINGUISHED US
SPEAKERS.
TODAY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
THE LANDMARK LEGISLATION.
WE PASSED LAST YEAR.
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED HOW THE
LEGISLATURE CAN HELP ASSURE.
THEIR SUCCESS AND GIVEN THE
COMPLEXITY OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS.
I'M EAGER TO HEAR FROM OUR
PANEL HOW WE CAN BUILD UPON LAST
YEAR SUCCESS.
TO RESOLVE THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN.
THANK YOU OF SO MUCH FOR.
WORKING WITH ME ON THESE BILLS.
.
BILL THAT I WORK ON PERSONALLY
IT TOOK GOOD.
.
THREE AND A HALF FOUR YEARS OF
HARD WORK.
.
WORKING NOT A DOUBT LONG BEFORE
IT BECAME A.
LAW AND I LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR HELPING INCLUDING.
.
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WAS GONNA SAY
SENATOR.
NOT QUITE.
AYE I TREAT IT LIKE A SENATOR.
BUT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DAVID THANK YOU CENTER
AND I LIKE TO TREAT YOU LIKE AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WHILE PAUL AYE I DID THE JOB.
FOR SIX YEARS.
YEAH ARE WITH THAT LET ME ASK IF
WE HAVE ANY OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
STATEMENTS.
OKAY SEEN NONE ONE A WE I GO
STRAIGHT TO THE FIRST PANEL WE
HAVE ALL THE HEADS OF TWO OF THE
MAJOR STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. IMPLEMENTING.
OR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
HOUSING PACKAGE.
MISTER MAC HEALTH.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND TEAR BOOKMAN
PATTERSON WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CAL.
HFA.
WITHOUT.
ONE I TURN IT OVER TO A DIRECT
CONNECT HEALTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON A TERRIBLE
CHAIRMAN CHU AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE IT'S.
A REAL HONOR TO BE ABLE TO CHAT
WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
WORK WE'RE DOING AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMUTED
ELEMENT.
AND IS WAS A PERSON I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SPARE PARTITION
COLLABORATION THAT WE'VE ENJOYED
WITH YOU ALL AND YOUR STAFF AND
OTHER WORK THAT THE LIES AHEAD
OF US.
BUT LET ME START.
BY PUTTING A SLIDE UP HERE
DIGITAL CONTEXT OR ON THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING.
.
AND THIS IS NOT AN UNFAMILIAR
DATA POINT TO THOSE OF YOU
WORKING ON HOUSING ISSUES BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT FOR.
DECADES NOW CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
UNDER BUILDING HOMES ESPECIALLY
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING. RELATIVE
TO WHAT WE KNOW WE'VE NEEDED TO
PUTTING ONLINE.
WE PROJECT.
A A NEED FOR A MINIMUM OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND NEW
HOMES ANNUALLY. JUST TO KEEP UP
WITH ARE PROJECTED GROWTH
HOWEVER.
IF PAST IS PROLOGUE.
WE HAVE SOME CAUSE FOR CONCERN
WE'VE ONLY AVERAGED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY THOUSAND
HOMES EACH OF THE.
PREVIOUS YEARS OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST DECADE.
AND THAT'S LESS THAN HALF WHAT
WE ARE BUILDING IN MOST THE
TWENTY CENTURY.
WHEN OUR BASS POPULATION HERE
CALIFORNIA WAS MUCH LOWER.
BUT UNDER PRODUCTION OF TIGHT
SUPPLY OF COURSE HAS ALSO BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE EVENTS OF THE
FALL WITH THE NATURAL DISASTERS
VERTICALLY THAT IMPACTED THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA.
I TAKING OFF LINE.
ALMOST AS MANY HOMES IN ONE
FELL SWOOP AS ARE BUILT IN
TYPICAL YEAR IN THE ENTIRE BAY
AREA.
THESE.
NUMBERS.
BEAR OUT AS WELL IN TERMS OF
THE EFFECT THAT THEY HAVE ARE
HOMELESS POPULATION WE NOW HAVE
THE DUBIOUS DISTINCTION OF
HAVING THE HIGHEST RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS.
OF ANY STATE IN THE NATION.
WE SEE OUR FIRST TIME
HOMEOWNERS.
TYPICALLY MILLENNIALS AND.
FOLKS REPRESENTING COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR BEING PRICED OUT THE
MARKET.
DID RISING COSTS.
WE SEE THE GAP BETWEEN AVERAGE
INCOMES AN ACTUAL RENTS CONTINUE
TO WIDEN WITH TODAY.
NOW ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS UNABLE TO
ACCESS RENTAL ASSISTANCE IN
PAYING. MORE THAN HALF THEIR
INCOME. AND HOUSING COSTS EVERY
MONTH.
A AS THE BOTH OF THE.
CHAIRMAN NOTED. WELL LAST YEAR.
WAS.
ENCOURAGING WE MADE SOME VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
IN TERMS OF PUTTING TOGETHER A
PACKAGE OF BILLS IDENTICALLY
THAT THAT.
.
BEHIND NANCY AND DAVID THERE.
NANCY SKINNER THAT'S ME IN THE
BACK.
DO WE KNOW.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A LITTLE JOKE
YOU'RE LE.
AND.
.
WHAT WAS A PARTICULARLY I THINK?
IMPRESSIVE WAS THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE IN THIS PACKAGE THAT
THERE WAS AND IS NO SILVER
BULLET TO ADDRESSING THE DECADES
OF SHORTAGE THAT WE'VE HAD. BUT
RATHER A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
WAS NEEDED WITH WITH
STREAMLINING WITH THE FORCE OF
WITH PRESERVATION.
AND OF COURSE WITH FUNDING.
I'M I'M NOT GONNA GO THROUGH.
THE SPECIFICS OF ALL OF THESE
BILLS.
THAT WERE BUNDLED TOGETHER.
BUT WILL KNOW.
THAT.
THEY COVER THE GAMUT FROM THE
WORKING LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS
SEIZE.
INCREASING OUR STATE
ENFORCEMENT ONTO EXISTING
HOUSING OBLIGATIONS WORKING TO
ASSURE THAT WE'RE NOT LOSING.
ANY OF THE FOUR WHEEL HOUSING
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE
HISTORICALLY MADE.
AND OF COURSE IDENTIFYING NEW
FUNDING SOURCES THAT CAN ADDRESS
ISSUES LIKE HOMELESSNESS LIKE
RENTAL HOUSING LIKE AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
IN JANUARY ALSO OFFERS.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THE
DEPARTMENT BUT TO ENSURE THAT IN
FACT WE CAN.
PROMPTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THE HOUSING PACKAGE.
BUT IT THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
REQUESTS FOR NEW POSITIONS.
ADVANCE PREPARATION ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS FOR THE
PERMANENT SOURCE FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO. PUT THAT MONEY UP
FASTER.
APPROPRIATE THIRTY TO BEGIN WORK
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
SB THREE THE BOND.
AS WELL AS FUNDS TO DEVELOP OF
A FEE COST STUDY TO BRING BACK
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE.
FOR FURTHER CHANGE THAT WE CAN
MAKE UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF AB
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE.
AND IN FACT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS PACKAGE OF BILLS YOU'LL SEE
THAT A FAIR AMOUNT OF WORK TO
DO.
WITH ASSISTANCE FROM ANY OF OUR
SISTER AGENCIES COLLEGE OF FAYE.
THE TREASURE DEPARTMENT CALVET
OFFICE IT COVERS OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH IN OTHER
STATE AGENCIES.
EACH CITY WILL BE IMPLEMENTING.
THESE BILLS FROM START TO
FINISH.
SPECIFICALLY WILL ISSUE NOTICES
THE FUNDING AVAILABILITY FOR SP
TWO SP THREE AND ALL PROGRAMS
THERE AND.
FOR S. B. FIVE FORTY FOUR AB
SEVENTY THREE.
WILL BE DEVELOPING IMPLEMENTING
GUIDELINES FOR.
.
AS BE TWO AND THREE AS WELL AS
THE S. B. THIRTY FIVE FIVE FORTY
SEVEN THREE AB IT'S ONLY NINE
MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE.
AND FOR ALL THE BILL'S THE
PACKAGE WILL BE WORKING AS BEST
WE CAN'T PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH A VARIETY
VEHICLES TO HELP FOLKS. AS THEY
WORK TO IMPLEMENT THESE NEW
AUTHORITIES.
NOW WE ARE DON'T DO THIS ALONE
THAT A CITY.
WE START A PRESUMPTION THAT
THIS WORK A IS IS ROOTED AND.
EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN UNDER WAY
FOR AWHILE.
AND OR INFORMED BY PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION.
ALL THIS PAST DECEMBER WE
DEVELOPED A RESOURCE SECTION UP
ON OUR WEBSITE THAT DEDICATED TO
THE HOUSING PACKAGE.
WITH OVER VIEWS OF EACH THE
BILL'S AT AN EMAIL ADDRESS FOR
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
THERE ARE TO THE SERVICE A
RESOURCE TO THE PUBLIC.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR
WE STARTED A PROCESS OF REACHING
OUT OF FORMALLY TO STAKEHOLDERS
FOR. A ONE ON ONE INTERVIEWS
APRENDIDO SMALL FACILITY FOCUS
GROUPS.
PARTNERING WITH VARIOUS.
HOUSING AND STAKEHOLDER
ORGANIZATIONS TO BEGIN TO
COLLECT SOME OF THE INITIAL
INPUT AND FEEDBACK.
EARLIER THIS MONTH WE ALSO
UPLOADED TO OUR WEB PAGE.
A FIRST BATCH OF WEEKLY ASK
QUESTIONS TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF
SOME OF THE ISSUES THE PARTY
STARTED COMMAND. AS WELL AS
PUTTING UP A SERIES OF
MILESTONES THAT WE ANTICIPATE
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EACH
OF THESE.
A NEW LOS.
WOW THIS SPRING WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE AS ROBUSTLY AS WE CAN.
WITH A VARIETY OF HOUSING
CONFERENCES AND FORUMS.
WE DO PLATYPUS PEYTON RESULT
PUBLIC FORUMS.
THROUGH THE SUMMER.
AND THEN.
STARTING IN JULY. OUR EACH CD
ITSELF WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
PUTTING TOGETHER IN A MORE
FORMAL WAY A WORKSHOPS A.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT OPPORTUNITIES
ON GUIDELINES AND NOTICES A
FUNDING AVAILABILITY AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DOCUMENTS.
THIS WORK WILL FOLLOW A. A. BUT
THE TRADITION THAT WE HAVE HAD A
CD OF ROBUST PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
FROM START TO FINISH IN TERMS OF
DEVELOPING FINE TUNING AND
HONING OUR PROGRAMS INVESTMENTS
AND AUTHORITIES.
HERE ON THE SLIDE IS AN EXAMPLE
OF SOME OF THE RESOURCES AND NEW
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE BEGUN TO
MAKE AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
A HOUSING BILL SUMMARY FRICKLEY
ASK QUESTIONS OF INFORMATION
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
HOUSING PRODUCTION DATA. AND OUR
INTENTION IS TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
US UPDATED ON ONGOING FASHION
WITH NEW RESOURCES INFORMATION.
AND ANSWER QUESTIONS AS THEY
COME IN.
WE GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT WE PUT OFF
RECENTLY.
BUT THIS IS OUR.
.
METHODOLOGY AND DETERMINATION
LIST FOR SENATE BILL THIRTY
FIVE.
THIS DETERMINATION LIST WAS NOT
NECESSARY FOR THE BILL AND
ORDERS TRUMAN IN WHICH CITIES
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE S. B.
THIRTY FIVE AUTHORITY.
BUT IN FACT THE WORK THAT SPRUNG
FROM IT.
SPRING FROM A YEAR LONG EFFORT
BY THE DEPARTMENT.
TO BEGIN TO MOVE MORE HOUSING
DATA TO OPEN SOURCE FORMAT.
OUR HOUSING ELEMENT OPEN DATA
PROJECT ACTUALLY HAS TWO DATA
TOOLS EMBEDDED IN IT THAT
INCREASE THE TRANSPARENCY OF
HOUSE CITIES ARE PLANNING. FOR
THE HOUSING THAT THEY INTEND TO
PROVIDE TO MEET THE HOUSING
GOALS.
AND ALSO HOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY
PERFORMING IN REAL TIME IN TERMS
MEETING KNUCKLES AND PERMITTING
ADDITIONAL UNITS.
WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE ON THIS MAP
OF CAN'T SEE IT VERY CLEARLY BUT
I HAVE A COUPLE OF WILL BLOW UPS
OF THE BAY AREA AS WELL AS OF
LOS ANGELES?
AND OTHER REGIONS ARE AVAILABLE
ON THE WEBSITE THAT ACTUALLY
SHOW GRAPHICALLY.
THAT TODAY.
ARE TOOL SUGGESTS THAT SEVENTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS.
ARE FALLING BEHIND IN TERMS OF
DELIVERING ON.
MULTIPLE CATEGORIES OF HOUSING
THAT THEIR REAL HOUSE NEEDS
ALLOCATIONS.
INDICATING IS PROVIDING FOR.
AND NINETY SEVEN PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA JURISDICTION SO
BASICALLY THE ENTIRE STATE.
IS FALLING BEHIND.
AND IS OFF PIECE FOR AT LEAST
ONE OF THEIR SIX CYCLE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEED ALLOCATION GOALS.
WERE ALSO ESPECIALLY PROUD TO
BE.
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAMS
IDENTIFIED UNDER THE BUILDING
JOBS AND HOME ACT.
TO.
AND AS A REMINDER.
THAT LAW.
PURSUANT TO STATUTE AYE DIVIDES
UP THE FUNDING AND THE RECEIPTS
THAT ARE COLLECTED THROUGH THE
PERMIT WERE WERE.
PRODUCTIVE RECORDING FEE.
EQUALLY DURING THE FIRST YEAR
WITH HALF GOING TO STATE
ADMINISTER PLANTING PLANNING
GRANTS TO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
AT HALF GOING TO HOMES PROGRAMS.
THE PLAN GRANTS.
WILL BE A RESOURCE FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO OUR CAPACITY.
AROUND PLANNING AND ZONING ORDER
PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS.
SO THEY CAN STREAMLINED HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
PROGRAMS ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
WILL BE MINISTER STATEWIDE AND
WE'LL ALL BE OFFERED A FOR
JURISDICTIONS AND FOR DEVELOPERS
TO APPLY FOR THOSE FUNDS TO
ADDRESS THE RISING RATE OF
HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS AN EXCITING.
NOT LAW THAT THIS IS A
PERMANENT GUARANTEED ONGOING
FUNDING SOURCE FOR HOUSING.
SO YOU SEE TO THE RIGHT AS WELL
OF THE FUNDS AT THE BOTTOM
EXCUSE ME THE FUNDS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BE IN A PERMITS SOURCE
COMING IN EVERY YEAR. YEAR AFTER
YEAR.
WITH SEVENTY PERCENT ACTUALLY
BEING LOCALLY ADMINISTERED
PURPOSES OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE DIVIDED
BETWEEN. LARGER MIDSIZE
JURISDICTIONS THAT RECEIVE THEIR
FUNDS DIRECTLY.
AS WELL AS A WE CALL NON
ENTITLEMENT JURISDICTION GROUP
THAT WILL BE.
I MINISTER COMPETITIVELY AT THE
STATE LEVEL BUT ALL CALIFORNIA
JURISDICTIONS WILL BE RECEIVING
AT LEAST.
AT SOME FUNDING.
THURMOND THIRTY PERCENT OF THE
FUNDS IN THE OUT YEARS. THAT
WILL BE STATE ADMINISTERED WITH
A FIFTEEN PERCENT ADMINISTERED
BY KELLY JEFF A WHICH TO YOU
WILL TALK ABOUT FIVE PERCENT
PRODUCTIONS HAD TO PROGRAMS AT
TEN PERCENT.
FOR FARMWORKERS HOUSING.
THE PROVIDED HERE JUST A LITTLE
A SKETCH OF.
HOW THESE FUNDS WILL ACTUALLY
ROLLOUT AT THIS POINT THIS IS
OUR BEST GUESS PROJECTION?
AS THOSE FEES COME IN.
WE ARE LOOKING TO DEVELOP SOME
OF OUR INITIAL GUIDELINES FOR
COMMENT LATER THIS SUMMER. WE'RE
LOOKING AT.
HOPEFULLY PUTTING OUT OUR FIRST
KNOWS FUNDING AVAILABILITY FOR
THE INITIAL CHUNK OF FUNDING ON
THE HOMES OF SYRIA.
BY THE FALL AT SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE PHOTOGRAPHS I
LATER THIS YEAR PLANNING GRANTS
THEMSELVES BEING MADE AVAILABLE
INITIALLY IN SPRING TWENTY
NINETEEN.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WERE
STILL BURNING HUTCH IN THE MIX
HERE IN TERMS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT.
PACIFIC'S OF HOW WE CAN MAKE
THESE FUNDS AVAILABLE IN A WAY
THAT IS. OUR EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT
BUT DELIVERING ON THE POLICY
GOAL TO THAT AND WE'VE BEEN
BUSY.
ARE TALKING TO STAKEHOLDER
SOLICIT FEEDBACK AND INPUT ON
USES AND HOW THE FUND SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED. AND ATTEND TO
CONTINUE TO DO BROUGHT OUT
REACH.
TO.
A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS.
IN AUGUSTA HOMELESSNESS DOLLARS
I DO WANT TO JUST SAY WE ARE
VERY FOCUSED ON MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY TO SUPPORT LOCAL
PRIORITIES INVESTMENTS.
CREATING PERMITS SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROVIDING RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND HOUSING
SUBSIDIES.
A PAPER SUPPORTIVE SERVICES AND
APPROVING THE PERFORMANCE AND
LEVERAGING THE EXISTING HORSES
PROGRAMS THAT WE ALREADY HAVE US
TOOLS IN OUR QUIVER OURS AN
ACQUITTAL.
A CHECHEN REBELS MENTIONED
SEVERAL THREE THE BETTER THAN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BOND ACT.
SUBJECT VOTER APPROVAL OF THIS
BOND ACT WILL PROVIDE A ONE AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT AND INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR REFER TO
MILLION FOR CAL HOME.
AND BEGIN THREE OTHER MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE STERN A FARM
WORKER HOUSING PROGRAM. THREE
MILLION TO LOCAL HOUSING TRUST
FUND MATCHING GRANT. THESE ARE
UP BUT THESE ARE TRIED AND TRUE
OVER COURSE PROGRAMS WHICH HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN FUNDED THROUGH
PASS BOND MEASURES BUT FOR WHICH
THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN EXPANDED AND
US S. B. THREE OFFERS US A
CHANCE TO REFILL THOSE COFFERS.
IN ADDITION TO THIS WORK ON
HOUSING PACKAGE OF COURSE THE
CITY IS ALSO VERY BUSY WITH A
NUMBER OF THE THINGS THAT. WE'VE
BEEN DOUBLING DOWN ON WHAT'S
WORKING ALREADY WITH OUR
EXISTING PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PROGRAM
FUNDED THROUGH CAPITA TRADE.
IMPROVING OUR ADMINISTRATION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS SUCH AS THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM.
AND OF COURSE DOING THINGS LIKE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT.
THROUGH TO THOSE AREAS IMPACT
BY DISASTERS AND TO ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE OFFER. ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF REALITIES THAT
DISASTER SURVIVORS IN
COMMUNITIES.
BASS.
THANK YOU FOR READING HERE
TODAY.
FACILITIES LEAVE YOU WITH A FEW
WAYS THAT I'M HOPING.
YOU CAN FOLLOW OUR PROGRESS AS
WE WORK TO IMPLEMENT THESE THIS
PACKAGE AND OTHER ACTIVITIES IN
BILLS.
FIRST ALL WE DO HAVE A HOUSING
PACKAGE PAGE OF OUR WEBSITE.
WE HAVE.
.
JOINT TEN THOUSAND OTHER
SUBSCRIBERS ON OUR EMAIL LIST
SERVE A FOLLOW US ON TWITTER
FACEBOOK. A PLEASE LET YOUR
CONSTITUENTS KNOW THAT WE ARE
EAGER TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AS
THEY COME IN AND LOOKING FORWARD
AS I SAID TO DOING THIS.
INEQUALITY WAY.
WITH.
APPROPRIATE.
SPEED.
I AM A FORGER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER DIRECTOR I
DON'T THINK AT THIS POINT
ANOTHER PUBLIC COUPLE QUESTIONS
THAT RECTOR THAT ONE WE TAKE
THEM NOW BEFORE WE GO ON. TO THE
NEXT PRESENTATION.
CENTER BILL DO YOU WANNA START.
OKAY JUST GO.
TERMS OF THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION OUT REACH FOR THE.
SP THREE.
CAN YOU GIVE US A MORE DETAILED
IDEA ABOUT.
HOW YOU GOING TO DO THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE?
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OR.
HOW YOU HOW YOU PLAN ON GOING
TO?
?
THAT ISSUE.
YEP SO WE ALTHOUGH THESE ARE.
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
INVESTED IN THE PAST WE ARE
LOOKING AT THESE AGAIN WITH
FRESH EYES AND. HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN THE PROCESS OF ENGAGING
MANY OF OUR STAKEHOLDER
ASSOCIATIONS TO TO TO ASK THEM
TO.
PROVIDE TO BEGIN WORKING WITH
THEIR MEMBERS TO BEGIN PROVIDING
IMPORTANT BOUGHT TWO WAYS WE CAN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE.
ONCE WE.
HAVE THE A VOTER INITIATIVE.
IN HAND AND IT HAS BEEN PASSED
THAT WE WILL.
AS WE HAVE DONE IN THE PAST
VIEW LOOKING TO PUT OUT IN DRAFT
FORM.
UPDATES TO OUR GUIDELINES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL HOLD
REGIONAL FORUMS WEBINARS.
WILL BUT THAT WILL HAPPEN LATER
IN THE FALL AND EARLY IN THE
WINTER.
OKAY ON SP TO.
LOOK LIKE YOUR.
THE MONEY WILL BE.
.
HOW WOULD YOU SAY UP FOR GRABS
PRETTY QUICK?
OF IN TERMS OF SOLICITATION
ESPECIALLY FOR THE.
.
DESPERATE HOMELESS.
ISSUE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
COPE WITH YOUR.
OF. HOW SOON CAN WE GET THAT?
THE SENATE TO OF FUNDING.
AVAILABLE AND OUT THE DOOR.
SO YOU SUBJECT TO A PUBLIC AND
ASIA PROCESS WHICH WILL BE.
PICKING UP IN THE LATE SPRING
AND SUMMER OUR PLAN IS TO PUT
THE FIRST CHUNK OF MONEY OUT IN
THIS FALL. THROUGH NOTICE OF
FUNDING AVAILABILITY EX THAT
WOULD GO OFF THE FIRST TWO
QUARTERS OF FUNDS COLLECTED.
AND I SUCH WINDOWS OF FUNDING
AVAILABILITY WITH THE FINAL TWO
QUARTERS OF COUNTY HERE THAT
WILL BE RELEASED IN THE
SUMMERTIME ESTAMOS SUMMERS WHEN
HOUSING.
STATEMENT GENERAL ESTIMATE ARE
YOU KNOW OUR OUR ENTIRE DETAIL
YEAH OR WE WE REALLY WON'T KNOW
UNTIL MAY ONE.
WHEN OUR FIRST QUARTER REVENUES
ARE COLLECTED.
THE NUMBER THAT WE HAVE BEEN
BUDGETING HAS BEEN TO IN A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE COURSE
THE COUNTER HERE BUT. THAT
NUMBER IS BASED ON A NUMBER OF
ASSUMPTIONS WHICH YOU HAVE HEARD
PUBLIC IN AND DO A WIN. JANUARY
ONE JANUARY ONE.
SIERRA MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU A CHECK TO MAKE HAVE
BEEN HERE FOR THE PRESENTATION
OF KIND OF PICKING UP WORST
CENTER BELL WAS JUST A MOMENT
AGO.
YOU RECOGNIZE THE URGENCY OF
THE SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA OF
IRA BY.
RESPECTS AT THE SENATOR TALKED
ABOUT GETTING THIS OUT FAIRLY
QUICKLY I'M NOTICING THAT IT
COULD BE A YOU MORE THAN A YEAR
BEFORE SOME THE PLANNING GRANTS
ARE OUT THE DOOR. A CITY WITH IN
THIS COUNTY OR FOR THE HOMELESS
GRANTS.
I MONEY IS THERE ANYWAY TO SORT
OF SPEED UP THAT PROCESS I THINK
PARTICULARLY WHEN DEALING WITH A
NEW FEE OF WITH CHAU SOME FAITH
TO THE FOLKS PAIN THAT THAT WERE
ACTING URGENTLY I GET FROM THE
GENERAL PRESENTATION THAT YOU
ARE. BUT IS THERE ANYWAY TO
SPEED UP THE ALLOCATIONS
PARTICULAR WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HOMELESS GIVEN THE DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCE
THAT WERE IN.
UP UP UP SO ON THE WHOLE ON THE
HOMELESS IS RUNNING A PARTICULAR
IT IS THE QUESTION YET START
THERE YEAH A PLAYGROUND.
.
YOU KNOW THE DARK CHALLENGE I
THINK IS THAT WE DO NEED TO
FIGURE OUT.
SO I ASK YOU TO PROVIDE US WITH
BROAD FLEXIBILITY ON ON HOW WE
MIGHT USE THOSE FUNDS THERE ARE
A VARIETY OF WAYS THE STATE
HISTORICALLY SUPPORTED. POLICIES
ACTIVITIES.
THAT RANGE FROM.
ARMOR SOLUTIONS GRANT EFFORTS
TO BUILDING PERMITS FOR HOUSING
TO RAPIDLY HOUSING WE DO NEED TO
DO A LITTLE BIT OF WORK WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE USING THOSE
MONIES IN THE BEST POSSIBLE WAY
THAT DELIVERS. WHAT LOCALS WANT
ON AND I THINK IN THE SAME SENSE
OF TRYING TO ACCELERATE THE
TIMING THERE THE DECISION THAT
WE HAVE MADE AT THIS POINT?
IS TO.
GET STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK ON
PUTTING OUT A FIRST.
SLUGGER OF THE FUNDING ONCE WE
HAVE THE FIRST HALF OF THE YEAR
OF REVENUES COLLECTED BUT WE
WON'T EVEN HAVE THE FIRST HALF
OF THE YEAR COLLECTED UNTIL.
LATE JULY OUT TO BE ABLE TO
CALCULATE HOW MUCH WE HAVE WHICH
WILL INFORM HOW DIFFERENT
VESTMENTS MEADOW MAKE WHAT THE
GRANT SIZES MIGHT BE.
AND WILL NEED TO HAVE A SPACE
TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT'S
I THINK
CAN'T DO IT FASTER THAN THAT THE
FIRST OF MANY FAST AND FALL.
WITHOUT.
SHORT CIRCUITING THE QUALITY
PLANE YEAH SHE'S A LOOK AT THIS
THE NO IT'S NO FUN FALL RIGHT SO
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY AWARDING
GRANTS THROUGH.
I I GUESS OF A PART OF BESIDES
THE OBVIOUS URGENCY.
TERMS WHAT YOU SEPARATING
WALKING HERE TO OF TO MAKE THIS
PRESENTATION.
IS.
IT IS NOTHING NEW UNDER THE SUN
WHERE THIS STUFF IS CONCERNED
RIGHT WE KNOW IT'S HOUSING
NAVIGATION WE KNOW IT'S PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING.
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS MONEY
NEEDS TO BE USED FOR AND I
ALWAYS IN PERIL OR.
.
FRUSTRATED OCCASIONALLY IN
PEOPLE COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE TODAY
THAT WE HAVE TO STUDY THIS
ANYWAY WE WE KNOW WHAT THE
INTERVENTIONS ARE WE HAVE BEEN
FUNDING THE SAME THREE
NONPROFITS IN SAN DIEGO FOR A
MILLION YEARS TO DO THIS WHAT
THE PROBABLY THE ONES GOING AT
THESE MONIES.
AND I REALIZE THERE'S A THERE'S
THE CHALLENGE OF ACTUALLY
RECEIVING THESE FUNDS IN BEING
ABLE TO. WHATEVER AMOUNT OF THE
GRANT THAT WE GET TO MAKE GOOD
ON THAT AMOUNT BUT.
IT WILL. I JUST I I I I
UNDERSTAND ME TO USE THIS MONEY
WISELY AND JUDICIOUSLY AT THE
SAME TIME.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY KEYS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA DON'T HAVE
MEASURES ON THE BALLOT THIS
FALL.
AND WE NEED TO SHOW THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS ALREADY BEING
USED WELL SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
THE ARGUMENT WHITE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY IF THAT
MAKES.
SO. LET ME JUST IN AND SAVE MY
COLLEAGUE. US SO IS THE
NECESSARY THEN WELL THE. WE DO
HAVE A SPECIAL NEEDS HOUSING
PROGRAM THAT IS BEING
ADMINISTERED AT CALLIE TO FAYE
IN CONJUNCTION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT
AND THAT IS USING VOLUNTARY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE ACT FUNDS.
THAT FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
VOLUNTARILY WE HAVE FOURTEEN
OVER FOURTEEN JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING THAT SO WE ARE
FUNDING HOMELESS HOUSING FOR
HOPE THAT FOR FOLKS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS OR THEIR FAMILIES NOW.
AND THAT PROGRAM IS ALL
INVOLUNTARY PROGRAM THAT WAS
MEANT TO SERVE IS THE TRANSITION
UNTIL THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
PROGRAM COMES UP AND IS RUNNING.
IN ADDITION OF THAT VIA SOME OF
OUR MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
FINANCING THAT WE'RE FINANCING
AND USING OVER THE COUNTER.
THERE ARE PARTNERSHIPS RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE OCCURRING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN WHICH THEY ARE
MAKING SURE THAT A PORTION OF
THOSE MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS SO WE JUST APPROVED
A PROJECT LAST WEEK WITH THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND WHICH WE
CAME IN WITH OUR PERMANENT LOOK
FIRST LING LANDING AND THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE BROUGHT IN SOME OF
THEIR. FUNDING FROM LOCAL
JURISDICTION AND THEY'RE SETTING
ASIDE TEN PERCENT OF THAT ENTIRE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE HOMELESS AND
SO WE ARE DOING OUR SHARE TO
COMPLEMENT ONE ANOTHER. SO THERE
ARE PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW IN THE
STATE THAT ARE UP AND RUNNING
THAT ARE FOR FUNDING THOSE
PROGRAMS WITH EXISTING PROGRAMS
OF EXISTING RESOURCES WOULD HAVE
AT THE NEW RESOURCES OF SP TO A
POTENTIALLY SP THREE. THINK
UNDERSTAND THAT I'M ASKING
QUESTIONS THAT TOO BECAUSE I'M
ANTICIPATING VOTER RATIFICATION
OF THREE AND I'M HOPING THAT WE
WHATEVER PROCESS IS IT GOING TO
GET THESE DOLLARS AT THE DOOR
THAT THAT FOR THE PROCESS FOR
THREE. WILL BE EVEN QUICKER
HOPEFULLY.
JUST TO PROVIDE APPOINTED TO
KNOW FOR FOR THE HOMELESS MONEY
GOES OUT IN THE FALL TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN MIGHT THE
DEPARTMENT MAKE AWARDS OF THOSE
FUNNY.
SIXTY NINETY DAY PERIOD FOR
FOLKS TO
BUT THE OTHER APPLICATIONS AND
THEN.
BUT IN THE NINETY DAY PERIOD TO
DISLIKE TO MAKE THOSE WORDS.
DEPENDING ON HOW BUT THERE'S
FUNDS OUT WE MIGHT FEEL BETRAYED
THAT DOWN A LITTLE BIT SO SPRING
OF TWENTY NINETEEN GROW THE
ACTUAL CRASH CASH ON HAND TO DO
THE PROGRAM. ANYTHING WE CAN DO
TO MOVE THAT ALONG AND I REALIZE
THAT CONSTRICTIONS ON THAT BUT
BOTTOM WHEN WE TOOK THIS VOTE IN
THE FALL OF TWENTIES.
SEVENTEEN RIGHT TO TO DO THIS
I'D I GET THE SENSE YOU'RE
MOVING QUICKLY BACK THINK WE
HAVE TO SHOW THAT WE'RE WORKING
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE NEED WE'RE
GOING BACK TO VOTED FOR S. B.
THREE. I THINK THAT MAYBE LEASE
TO INITIATIVE TO MY DISTRICT
WITH REGARD TO HOMES FUNDING.
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE CONCERT
THE LAST QUESTION IS CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME IS THE
PLANNING GRANT FOR NO FLAWS.
THAT YOUR SCOPING OUT WHAT THAT
COULD BE USED FOR CURRENTLY HAS
WHEN WE VOTED ON THIS IT WAS
SORT OF GENERAL PLAN UPDATING
KIND OF THING. I RECOGNIZE AGAIN
THE SENSE OF URGENCY BEHIND THIS
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND IMPATIENT
YOUNG MAN.
BUT THE IF THE IF THE DEMOCRAT
UPDATES CAN TAKE YEARS RIGHT IS
THERE IS THERE ANY EMPHASIS
BEING PLACED OUTSIDE WE'RE
BUILDING A NEW THREE BILLION
DOLLAR LIGHT RAIL LINE IN MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. YOU KNOW
COULD BE A SPECIFIC PLAN FOR FOR
COMMUNITIES AROUND THAT OR IS
THERE A WAY THE CITY'S TRYING TO
FOUR MINUTES SO THE STATE IS
TRYING TO FORCE COMMUNITIES. TO
REALLY LOOK AT WHERE THE
PLANNING MIGHT ACTUALLY GIVE US
THE MOST YIELD OF OUR HOUSING
CRISIS.
USB TWO IS CLEAR THAT THESE ARE
THESE ARE PLANNING GRANTS TO
ACTUALLY ACCELERATE THE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING AND RECIPIES THESE
FUNDS WILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SHOW THAT THESE ARTISTS ARE
TAKING OR PLAN OFF THE SHELF
AND.
UPDATING FOR THE SAKE OF
UPDATING BUT THESE ARE ACTUALLY
INTERVENTIONS THAT SHOULD LEAD
TO INCREASED SUPPLY.
YEAH AND I THINK OF AS ONE AS WE
ARE GOOD PUTTING OUT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THE BILL DOES
PROVIDE FOR STATE BECAUSE THIS
IS RESOURCES. WE ARE
PRIORITIZING DOES AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO WE CAN ACCESS OR TO
GET OUT AND WORK WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO HELP THEM. UP MAKE
SURE THE APPLICATIONS THAT BRING
THE OF PLANNING GRANTS ARE THE
BEST INTERVENTIONS THEY CAN. BUT
IT WILL ALSO GET A LOT OF
SUPPORT FROM MANY OF THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT REPRESENT
CITIES AND COUNTIES WHO REALLY
WANT TO MAKE PEACE.
FUNDS WORK WHILE THE STATUTE IS
FLEXIBLE AND IT ALLOWS THEM TO
DO THINGS LIKE USE THESE DOLLARS
TO. FUND A PROGRAM NOT JUST OF
ZONE TO IMPROVE PROCESS EASIER
PERHAPS WITHIN THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENT THEIR NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT FOLKS CAN YOU THAT
WILL DO THAT WILL REALLY MOVE
THE NEEDLE WITH THESE FUNDS.
OKAY.
I AM AGAIN CAN YOU LEAVE ME
TODAY WITH THAT THAT WE REALLY
YOUR HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW THE
SENSE THAT SAN DIEGO WHAT'S FAST
URGENCY ON IT LET'S GO. ON THE
RED STOOD ON HIGH RIGHT PEOPLE
ARE HURTING AND WE NEED TO SEVEN
DOWN.
SOPPY SHE UNDERSTANDING THAT
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO HELP
YOU
THAT HAPPENED A WEEK HERE THANK
YOU THINK.
THANK WAS GLORIA AYE I WAS GOING
TO SAVE A NUMBER MY QUESTIONS
THAT YET BUT I WANT TO JUST ASK
ONE FOLLOW UP TO WHAT.
MISTER GLORY JUST ASKED AROUND
HOMELESSNESS.
OF IT I THINK FOR MANY OF US
LAST YEAR'S PACKAGE WAS REALLY
FOCUSED ON HOW WE. MOVE FORWARD
BUILDING HOUSING UP FOR WHAT
HOUSING AROUND THE STATE BUT THE
FOCUS WAS A LITTLE BIT LESS ON
HOMELESSNESS.
WHICH IS A CRISIS THAT HAS
CERTAINLY.
SKYROCKETED IN AND IN RECENT
YEARS OF AND OF ICE I CERTAINLY
KNOW THAT YOU WILL BE DEVOTING A
PORTION OF SP TWO AND PORTION OF
SP THREE FUNDS.
TO HOMELESSNESS ARM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOUR
DEPARTMENT IS BEEN REALLY
LOOKING AT THE ESG PROGRAM THE
EMERGENCY SHELTER GRANTS
PROGRAM.
AROUND RAPIDLY HOUSING AND I
THINK MANY OF US HAVE
APPRECIATED THAT. PROGRAM A BUT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT A
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
THE FORTY TWO PERCENT OF ALL
AMERICANS WHO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN HOMELESS FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW
MUCH OF THE THESE FUNDS WILL BE
GOING TO ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF
TRULY CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AS OPPOSED TO FOLKS
WHO? ARE HAPPY BECOME MORE
RECENTLY HOMELESS.
WHAT ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES
DEFINITELY IT'S OF SUPPORTING
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND WE IN THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE IN TERMS OF
BUILDING OUT WHAT'S CALLED
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM? THAT
ACTUALLY ALLOWS THE
JURISDICTIONS TO PRIORITIZE FOR
ANY HOUSING OPPORTUNITY THOMAS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND MOST CHRONIC AND
SO I THINK THAT THAT ARE A
HOMELESS DOLLARS ARE GOING OUT.
THROUGH.
TO SUPPORT THINGS LIKE PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSNG.
OUR EXPECTATION IS THAT
JURISDICTION'S WOULD BE
TARGETING THOSE UNITS FOR THE
FOLKS ARE MOST PLEASURABLE TO
EXIT THAT WE'RE PUTTING MONEY
OUT SUPPORT WITH RAPIDLY HOUSING
OR. RENTAL ASSISTANCE WILL BE
WORKING THIS JURISDICTIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE BENEFICIARIES
ARE THE ONES WITH THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
OKAY. GREAT THANK YOU WANNA CALL
ANSWER WIENER THEN.
MR STEINER'S.
I'VE THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I WON.
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IS REALLY
COMPLEMENT YEAH ITS CITY FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. OUR S. B.
THIRTY FIVE OR WORKED REALLY
HARD TO. OUGHT TO PASS IT AND.
AND.
YOU GUYS WERE JUST
ON IT SO QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY.
AND.
REALLY GOT THE STREAMLINING
LIST AL. I JUST WITHIN A MATTER
OF.
.
I MEAN WHAT A MONTH MAYBE.
AFTER THE EFFECTIVE DATE SO I
JUST ONE REALLY APPRECIATE
INCOME BUT YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
OF FOR JUST BEING SO PASSIONATE
AND DEDICATED TO GETTING IT
DONE.
I HAVE I HAVE A GREAT TEAM YOU
DO HAVE AN AMAZING TEAM RIGHT
AFTER THAT.
AND.
.
AND THAT STREAMING LIST WAS IT
WAS SO INFORMATIVE ARE TOO MANY
OF US INTO THE PUBLIC.
AND ON AYE OPENING AND SOME
WAYS.
OF.
I WAS A DEPRESSING BECAUSE I'M
AN OPTIMIST BY NATURE BUT AND I
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE IN A
MUCH BETTER DIRECTION BUT.
IT WAS SUPER ANTHONY BUT THAT'S
A BETTER WORD WITH SILVERY.
OTHER FACT THAT ARE AS YOU
MENTIONED ABOUT NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT. OF.
OF.
JURISDICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
NOT MEETING THEIR BELOW MARKET.
RATES SO BASICALLY ALMOST
EVERYONE.
AND THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
IT'S BECAUSE I.
IT GENERALLY.
FOR EXAMPLE NOT TO PICK ON
BEVERLY HILLS BUT THAT WAS ONE
THAT CAME OUT MANAGE TO
NEGOTIATE ARENA OF THREE UNITS
FOR AN EIGHT YEAR PERIOD.
.
AT AND.
SO THAT THAT'S REALLY AND SAN
FRANCISCO DID NOT MEET ITS BLOOM
MARKETS THIS IS A STATEWIDE
ISSUE THE COMMUNITIES ARE NOT
MEAN THEY'RE BELOW MARKET RATE.
AND FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT
GOT.
TRUE REAL NON LAUGHABLE RINA
ALLOCATIONS FOR BELOW MARKET
RATE YOU KNOW WE NEED HELP AND
SO. WHEN AUTUMN I DO WE NEED
REDEVELOPMENT DOCTOR STATES TO
DO MORE IN TERMS OF HELPING WITH
FUNDING.
ON BUT THE OTHER PIECE OF IT
WHICH YOU MENTIONED.
ARE BECAUSE WE'RE ALL GOING TO
WORK REAL HARD TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE GIVING COMMUNITIES TOOLS
TO BUILD. AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
IS THE.
OF WILL MARKET RATE PORTION OF
IT BECAUSE OUR FOR OUR MIDDLE
CLASS AYE WE'RE NEVER GONNA YOU
MIGHT YOU SUBSIDIZE OUR WAY. OUT
OF A PROBLEM AND OUR HOUSING
SUBSIDIES I AM IN MY VIEW NEED
TO BE REALLY FOCUSED ON ALL
INCOME PEOPLE. ARTICLES A MARKET
WILL NOT PRODUCE HOUSING IN MANY
AREAS AFFORDABLE. TO LOW INCOME
PEOPLE ODD BUT FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS WE JUST NEED MORE HOUSING
AND. I WE HAVE A DEFICIT
APPROACHING FOUR MILLION.
UNITS AND IT GOES UP BY ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. OPERA YEAR SO
IT SYSTEM AMASSING GAPING
DEFICIT.
I AND.
WHAT ARE THE STREAMLINING LIST
THAT A CD PUT OUT SHOWS IS THAT
OVER TWO THIRDS OF JURISDICTIONS
ARE NOT MEETING?
I EVEN THEIR MARKET RATE GOALS
OUR AND OUR.
AND IT SHOWED ALSO.
MORE I THINK A LOT OF US KNEW
THAT RINA IS BROKEN DOWN DIETERS
SO POLITICIZED THAT WE HAVE.
CITIES ARE ADJACENT TO EACH
OTHER IN VERY SIMILAR WITH
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT READ THE
NUMBERS YOU'VE WEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES BEING ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE ALLEN. OF WITH THEIR
COLLEAGUES ARE LOWER NOT RENEW
NUMBERS.
AND SO I THINK OF WHAT THE
STREAMLINING LIST SHOW IT TO TWO
THINGS IT. IT STARTED INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PROCESS AND I THINK
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING SOME
ATMOSPHERIC CHANGES AND SOME
CITIES AROUND THE STATE IN TERMS
OF ATTITUDE TOWARDS APPROVING
HOUSING.
A BUT IT ALSO SHOWED THE WORK
THAT REMAINS.
AROUND JUST GETTING MORE
HOUSING PRODUCED PERIOD AND
MAKING SURE THAT.
ARENA ALLOCATIONS ARE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ON SO THANK YOU FOR.
HELP HELPING TAKE A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP.
TO OUR VICE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE MISTER
STEINORTH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR.
SO THE RECENTLY RELEASED
TRAILER BILL BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
OUTLINES OF FUNDING FORMULA TO
TAKE IN CONSIDERATION.
THAT IS NOT IN MY OPINION TAKING
CONSIDERATION HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS MADE BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO WE'RE BACK TO
TOPIC HOMELESSNESS.
.
I BY REPRESENTS THE MEDINA
COUNTY AN AND THE ADJACENT
COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOTH
COUNTIES BEEN WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS. WITH LOCAL FUNDS TO
REALLY TRY AND REDUCE THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION SO WE
LOOK AT A POINT TIME COUNTY YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE BELOW WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING OUT OF THAT FOUR
THOUSAND HOMELESS BECAUSE IT
WORKED SO DILIGENTLY. OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS SO MY CONCERN IS
WHEN THE FORMULA WAS OUTLINED IN
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND WAS
DEVELOPED.
BLESSED THE CONSIDERATION OF
LOCAL PROGRESS IN HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
TAKING A
FEDERATION.
CSUS SO BUT THE. SP TWO VERY
CLEARLY ASKS THAT WE HAVE
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY IN TERMS THE
DISTRIBUTIONS THAT WE MAKE. OF
WHAT THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ASPIRES TO DO IS JUST CREATE A
FULL OR.
OF THE MINIMUM ELIGIBLE THAT
APPLICANTS FOR PROJECTS PROGRAMS
CAN'T COMPETE FOR THESE OTHER
THEY HAVE ELIGIBLE PROJECTS IT
DOESN'T.
A NICE A STATE OR BECAUSE DIRECT
ALLOCATION.
SO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE EXACTLY THE THINGS
THAT BE BUILT INTO ANY
PARTICULAR FUNDING A NOTICE OF
FUNDING UNAVAILABILITY. IN TERMS
OF PRIORITIZING PRIVILEGE FOLKS
WHO HAVE TRACK RECORD CAPACITY
EXPERTISE AND IT CAN PROVE THEY
CAN DELIVER.
SO I THINK WE CAN GET. BUT WE
CAN GET THERE WHILE THE SAME
TIME PROVIDING FOR THE
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY.
JACK BECAUSE I MEAN OF COURSE
WE'RE ALL APPEAR TRYING TO
IDENTIFY AND I UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY HOW THIS WILL MAKE A
DIRECT IMPACT IN THE DISTRICTS
THAT WE REPRESENT.
AND IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN REALLY GOOD
ACTORS
AND THEY'VE DONE A VERY GOOD JOB
AND TRYING TO REDUCE THEIR
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION COUNTY
THEY'VE DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB IN
REDUCING BY SEVENTY PERCENT.
SINCE I AM I THINK WAS TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT TO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT. I'M VARIATION SO
WHEN THEY LOOK AT AND THEY SAY
OKAY FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE WERE
HAVING THE DISCUSSIONS OF SP
TWO.
YOU KNOW FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF FOR FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
ALMOST THREE YEARS I GUESS.
MY SET SERVICE IN MEDINA COUNTY
EXPLAINED TO ME THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO BECOME A DONOR COUNTY.
WHERE THE AMOUNT OF DOLLARS THAT
WILL BE YOU KNOW FOR S. B. TWO
WILL BE REMOVED FROM OUR COUNTY
WILL NOT BE COMING BACK TO US
BECAUSE WE'VE ACTUALLY DONE A
REASONABLE JOB AND TRYING TO?
YOU KNOW DEAL WITH OUR
HOMELESSNESS CALVET
CONSIDERATIONS THERE SO MIKE MY
QUESTION FOLLOW UP THIS.
.
I WOULDN'T WOULD YOU CONSIDER
FUTURE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ADDRESS INVESTMENTS MADE LOCALLY
SO THAT OUR REGION DOES NOT SEE
ITSELF AS BEING JUST A
COMPLETELY DONOR REGION.
SO YEAH I THINK AS I SAID
EARLIER I THINK THOSE ARE THE
ISSUES THAT WILL SURFACE AS WE
DO GUIDELINE DEVELOPMENT AND
NOTICES A FUNDING AVAILABILITY
IN THE PAST WE HAVE.
PRIVILEGED FOLKS WHO COME IN
WITH CAPACITY IN TRACK RECORDS
OF BEING ABLE TO DELIVER SO I
THINK WE CAN WORK THAT OUT TO
THE MINISTER PROCESSES.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
GREAT UNLESS YOU'RE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME FOR
MISTER METCALF WHY DON'T WE.
WHAT WE HAVE MOVED TO HEARING
FROM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF?
CAL EACH OF A.
THIS BUILDING PATTERSON. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIR. AND
CHAIR.
AND SENATOR BELT FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I AM TOO BUT THE
PATTERSON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCY. AS YOU KNOW
COUCH FACE SERVES AS THE STATE'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BANKING WAS
CREATED TO DEVELOP PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
STATE GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE
CAPITAL INVESTORS.
TO CREATE ADDITIONAL HOW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
SINCE ITS CREATION CALCULATORS
OPERATED PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
THE CREATION OF AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY AND SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSING.
DOWN PAYMENT AND CLOSING COSTS
ASSISTANCE FOR FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS SPECIAL PROGRAMS IN
CONCERT WITH CITIES AND COUNTIES
SPECIAL NEED HOUSING FOR.
MENTALLY ILL INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND HOUSING FOR
VETERANS
THIS SCOPE IN APPROACHING
CONTINUUM OF HOUSING HAS HAD IS
ADDRESSED IN SOME OF COLLEGES
MISSION TO CREATE AND FINANCE
PROGRESSIVE HOUSING SOLUTIONS SO
MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE A PLACE
TO CALL HOME.
AS YOU HEARD FROM A MISTER
METCALF THE DIRECTOR BATES CD
OUR SISTER DEPARTMENT THE
MAJORITY OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HOUSING PACKAGE WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED BY HDTV OTHER
HOUSING POLICIES AND PROGRAMS.
CALVET YOU FACE ROLE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HOUSING
LEGISLATION COMES IN THE FORM OF
FUNDING FROM TWO BILLS SENATE
BILL TWO BY SENATOR ATKINS. AND
IF APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER SENATE. SENATE BILL
THREE BY SENATOR BELL.
KELLY TO BE PROMOTES AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BY OFFERING FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS THAT THE MARKET EITHER
DOES NOT PROVIDE OR PROVIDES AT
A HIGHER COST TO BORROWERS.
COUNTY BE OFFERS LOW COST DEBT
FINANCING FUNDED BY PRIVATE
CAPITAL MARKETS SIMILAR TO BANKS
WAYS EACH CD PROVIDES FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENT FUNDING
SUBSIDIES TO MAKE PROJECTS MORE
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE.
THOUGH OUR APPROACHES TO MEETING
OUR MISSION ARE DIFFERENT
CALIPHATE AND EIGHT CD
COMPLEMENT ONE ANOTHER AND HAVE
ACHIEVED SOME OF THE MOST
POSITIVE HOUSING COMPANY CAO OUT
COMES WHEN THE TWO ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE WORKED IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION.
TO SERVE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
INDUSTRY PARTNERS AND OUR
CUSTOMERS.
CALIPHATE SELF SUPPORTED AND
DOES NOT RELY ON THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND TO ADMINISTER ITS
LOAN PROGRAMS.
THE US COUCH OF A INTENDS TO USE
THE FUNDING FROM S. B. TUTU AND
POTENTIALLY THE FUNDS FROM S. B.
THREE TO EXPAND ALREADY
SUCCESSFUL LOAN PROGRAMS.
SINCE THE FRAMEWORK IS ALREADY
IN PLACE CALLIE TO FAYE IS READY
NOW TO IMPLEMENT ITS PIECE OF
THE HOUSING PACKAGE.
S. B. THREE THE FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR VETERANS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BOND OF. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WILL GO IN FRONT OF THE VOTERS
IN NOVEMBER AND SHOULD IT PASS A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED TO COUCH IF A FOR
USED FOR HOMEBUYER ASSISTANCE.
THE FUNDS WILL GO DIRECTLY INTO
OUR EXISTING MY HOME PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDES DOWN PAYMENT AND
CLOSING COSTS ASSISTANCE.
FROM ITS INCEPTION IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THROUGH THE END OF THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR ABOUT TWO AND A
HALF YEARS MY HOME HAS PROVIDED
ASSISTANCE TO MORE THAN NINE
THOUSAND LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
CALIFORNIA FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS.
WE ESTIMATE THAT UP ADDITIONAL
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION WE CAN
PROVIDE DOWN PAYMENT AND CLOSING
COSTS ASSISTANCE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA FIRST TIME
HOMEBUYERS.
OVER THE NEXT THREE TO SIX YEARS
DEPENDING ON MARKET CONDITIONS.
.
ONE OF THE INITIATIVES I WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT MYSELF SENATOR
WHAT CASKEY WALKIN IS.
.
YOU HAD STE LEGISLATION THAT
MADE IT EASIER TO BUILD SELF
THREE DWELLING UNITS. AND SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THROUGH OUR
PARTNERS IN CDF BUYS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF HOW CAN WE
PROVIDE LOW COST SPENDING SO
THAT WE CAN GET LENDING OR
FINANCING AVAILABLE. TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO HELP IN THE
FINANCING OF ASSESS REDRAWING
UNITS AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED TO
USE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ONE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SAN JOSE
AREA. IN WHICH WE PUT PLAN TO
PARTNER WITH THEM ONE BY
FINANCING PRODUCT PROCESS WE
TELLING UNITS I WANT TO JUST PUT
THAT PLUG IN THERE FOR THE
SENATOR.
SO ON OUR MULTI FAMILY SIDE FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAVE PROVIDED ABOUT
ONE BILLION AND FINANCING FOR A
HUNDRED MULTI FAMILY RENTAL
DEVELOPMENTS TO OUR FIRST THING
LENDING. CONDUIT FINANCING
OR-SUBORDINATE DEBT PROGRAMS.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE CREATED TO
PRESERVE SIX THOUSAND UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES INCLUDING
SENIORS VETERANS AND THOSE WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. JUST ABOUT HALF
OF THESE UNITS WERE NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN USING A
LIMITED POOL OF INTERNAL
RESOURCES TO FINANCE THE
CREATION OF PRESERVATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIA'S. OF LOWER INCOME
BRACKETS HOWEVER WE HAVE IN OUR
PIPELINE PROJECTS ON OUR MULTI
FAMILY SIDE THOSE THAT WILL BE
REGULATED TO SERVE PEOPLE MAKING
UP TO ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
PERCENT.
OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME SO WE
ARE SERVING LOW. AND LOWER END
AND COME ALL THE WAY TO MODERATE
INCOME AND I HEARD.
SENATOR WIENER SAY THAT WE
WEREN'T GOING TO SUBSIDIZE OUR
WAY OUT OF MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING
BUT I
INCOME HOUSING.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU DO HAVE MIXED
INCOME MULTI FAMILY DEVELOPMENT
YOU CAN CROSS SUBSIDIZE AND
THOSE DEVELOPMENTS ARE OFTEN
MORE SUSTAINABLE.
SO BEGINNING IN TWENTY NINETEEN
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF THE ESTIMATED
THIRTY TO FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERATED BY S. B. TO WILL BE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED TO
COLLEGE BAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CREATING. MIXED INCOME MULTI
FAMILY RESIDENTIAL HOUSING FOR
LOW TO MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
WE HAVE TAKEN NOTICE OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS HAS HIT THOSE AT
THE IN THE LOWEST INCOME
BRACKETS THE HARDEST.
BUT WE ALSO IT HAS ALSO HIT THE
WRITTEN BURDEN LOW TO MODERATE
INCOME FOLKS AND BOTH RULE
COMMUNITIES AND HIGH COST
COMMUNITIES.
FOR THIS POPULATION OF RENTERS
THERE GENERALLY IS NO EXISTING
STATE RENTAL HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND WE HAVE TERM THIS RENTAL
POPULATION THE MISSING MIDDLE
THOSE THAT INCOMES BETWEEN SIXTY
PERCENT A MRI AND A HUNDRED
TWENTY PERCENT I AM I AND JUST
GIVE YOU A DOLLAR FIGURE. HERE
IN SACRAMENTO THAT WOULD BE FOR
A FAMILY OF FOUR MAKING BETWEEN
FIFTY THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND.
THE INFUSION OF SP TWO FUNDS
INTO OUR EXISTING MULTIFAMILY
LENDING PROGRAMS WILL ALLOW US
TO EXPAND OUR MULTIFAMILY
LENDING TO SERVE A BROADER RANGE
OF INCOME LEVELS INCLUDING THE
MISSING MIDDLE.
NOT TO.
TAKE AWAY FROM THOSE AT THE
LOWER INCOME SO IT'S A BROADER
RANGE NOT TAKING AWAY PURCHASE
MAKING IT A BROADER RANGE OF
INCOMES.
THROUGH THAT THOUGH THE FUNDING
WON'T BE AVAILABLE UNTIL TWENTY
NINETEEN THE FRAMEWORK AND
LENDING PROGRAMS TO PUT THESE
FUNDS TO USE IS ALREADY IN
PLACE.
OUR EXISTING SMALL LOAN PROGRAM
AND GAP FINANCING PROGRAM WILL
BE EXPANDED TO FINANCE AND
INCENTIVIZE MIXED INCOME MOLTI
FAMILY DEVELOPMENTS AND SMALLER
DEVELOPMENTS IN SOME OF OUR RULE
COMMUNITIES.
WITH THE SMALL LOAN PROGRAM WE
PROVIDE LOANS TO SMALLER
DEVELOPMENTS THAT OTHER LENDERS
WON'T LEND TO. NOT ONLY WILL WE
PROVIDE LOW COST FINANCING OF
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION OR MORE
DEPENDING ON THE AREA WE HAVE
STREAMLINED THE LOAN PROCESS TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR LESS
EXPERIENCE DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF.
THE OTHER COLLEGE OF A PROGRAM
THAT WE USE S. B. TO FUNDS TO
EXPAND AND FINANCE MORE MIXED
INCOME DEVELOPMENTS IS OUR GAP
FINANCING PROGRAM.
THIS SUBORDINATE DEBT FINANCING
IS USED IN CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
PERMANENT LOANS OR CONDUIT
FINANCING IT IS A PROGRAM THAT
COULD BE A LINE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LEVERAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SUBORDINATE DEBT. IN
A WAY THAT STRETCHES LOCAL
RESOURCES TO CREATE MORE HOUSING
FOR LOW TO MODERATE INCOMES AND
PERCENT.
ASSEMBLYMAN GLORIA WE ARE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE'VE ALSO
WORKED WITH THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TO CREATE PARTNERSHIPS
IN WHICH WE CAN PULL OUR
SUBORDINATE DEBT. WITH OUR
FIRSTLY LOANS ARE CONDUIT ISSUE
IS TO GET THAT LOW COST
FINANCING DOWN TO THE DEVELOPERS
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE AND EXPAND.
OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK.
BOTH OF THESE MULTIFAMILY
LENDING PROGRAMS ARE OVER THE
COUNTER.
ARE ALREADY IN PLACE AND ARE
ALREADY SUCCESSFUL INFUSION OF
FUNDS FROM S. B. TWO WILL SIMPLY
ALLOW US TO SERVE A BROADER
RANGE OF CALIFORNIANS IN ME.
AND ANTICIPATED THAT YOU WOULD
ASK ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO
ENGAGE STAKEHOLDERS TO OUT TO TO
TO TO TO UTILIZE THESE FUNDS WE
HAVE BEEN PRO ACTIVELY ENGAGING
STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE LAST YEAR
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY AND OTHER MULTI FAMILY
PARTNERS. SUCH AS LOCAL HOUSING
AGENCIES AND STATE LAWMAKERS AN
ATTEMPT TO GATHER INFORMATIONS
ON CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC HOUSING
NEEDS AND THE BEST WAY TO
LEVERAGE THE ADDITIONAL. S. B.
TO FINANCING I PERSONALLY MET
WITH LAWMAKERS FROM AROUND THE
STATE AND HAVE SPOKEN HOUSING
DEVELOPERS LOCAL HOUSING AGENCY
STAFF HOUSING ADVOCATES AT
CONFERENCES AND OTHER GATHERINGS
OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS. AND IT
WAS THROUGH THESE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE DECIDED TO EXPAND THE
SMALL LOAN AND GAP FINANCING
PROGRAM AND THAT THIS WOULD BE
THE BEST USE OF THIS PERMANENT
FUNDING SOURCE.
WE WILL USE THE TIME UNTIL THE
S. B. TWO FUNDING COMES TO US
INTO AND TWENTY NINETEEN TO
CONTINUE OUR OUT REACH. TO THE
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL HOUSING
AGENCIES GATHERING FOCUS
GATHERING FOCUS GROUPS AND
HOSTING WORKSHOPS WILL BE AN
EFFICIENT WAY FOR CALIPHATE AND
ITS PARTNERS TO COLLABORATE ON
THE SMALLER DETAILS AND DRILL
DOWN TO THE BEST WAYS. THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE THE
MOST EFFICIENT USE OF THESE
FUNDS WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL AND THROUGH YOUR
COMMITTEE AND STAFF AND YOUR
REPRESENTATIVES. AS PART WE
PROGRESS AND UPDATE AND WE TO SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO EXCHANGE
IDEAS I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND I AM AVAILABLE
SHOULD YOU HAVE ANY QUESTION.
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES.
I'LL START WITH WITH ONE
QUESTION YOU REFERENCE THAT THE
MISSING MIDDLE.
BY DEFINITION MARKET RATE
HOUSING IS DEVELOPED WITH THE
MARKET RATE RESOURCES AND A LOT
OF THE LINE SURE OF OUR. HOUSING
DOLLARS GO TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH IS REALLY MORE FOR LOWER
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AND YOU ALLUDED TO THE FACT
THAT SOME OF YOUR DOLLARS GO TO
HELPING THAT MISSING MIDDLE.
SEGMENT OF BUT I THINK FOR MANY
OF OUR PERSPECTIVES THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH THAT IS IN THAT AREA TO
REALLY JUICE PRODUCTION. OF
MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING DO YOU
HAVE ANY DIFFERENT THOUGHTS
ABOUT OTHER THINGS AT OTHER
POLICIES THAT WE COULD BE
CONSIDERING IN THIS AREA. OTHER
DIRECTIONS YOUR AGENCY MIGHT BE
LOOKING AT TO.
TO PROMOTE MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
WELL I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO SEE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SOME BY
HOUSING PACKAGE IN SOME OF THE.
BILLS AND THAT MISTER METCALF
TALKED ABOUT I THINK THAT WILL
GO A LONG WAY I THINK CONTINUED
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I THINK LOOKING AT
SURPLUS PROPERTY I KNOW THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO WAS LOOKING AT AND
I'M WORKING WITH THE CITY OF.
SAN DIEGO AND THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO BOTH ON WAYS IN WHICH
WE CAN YOU SURPLUS PROPERTY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL OR AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO COMBINE THOSE RESOURCES
AND BRING DOWN THAT COSTS. TO BE
ABLE TO HELP WITH THE PRODUCTION
OF MORE MIXED INCOME AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING.
GREAT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SENATE BILL.
BOB.
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE PASSED.
ALL.
IF RISK THAT ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS WHICH CAN BE USED FOR.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IT'S.
CREATING A ZONE YOU CREATED A.
A FINANCING.
.
STRUCTURE. AND OF FUND A PROGRAM
USES STATE.
.
DEPARTMENTS.
INTERESTED AND.
BLENDING THEIR FUNDS FOR THESE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS WITH THOSE
KINDS OF LOCAL FUNDS THAT ARE
CREATED. THROUGH INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS.
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES OWNS.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY LA COUNTY WE
HAVE THE BOND FUNDS.
FOR. HOME BUYERS DISTANCE OF
THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
IS THAT IS THAT IS THAT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THAT THAT DECLARATION?
FUNDING OF.
SHE'S LEAVING NOW CENTER RIGHT
CAL SKIS.
.
FINANCING CENTER ACCOUNT CITIES.
THEY LEGISLATION.
JUST THAT WHILE YOU.
IS THERE SO SOME OF THE
SUBORDINATE DEBT FINANCING THAT
I'VE SEEN COME IN FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE COME IN THE
FORM OF RENTAL SUBSIDIES.
CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
HAVE PEOPLE SUBSIDIES ALL THE
WAY UP TO BOND PROCEEDS AND SO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE COMING
IN A VARIETY OF WAYS IN WHICH
THEY'RE COLLABORATING WITH OUR
FINANCING AND AND WERE SEEN THAT
COME TOGETHER. SO I I I'M OPEN
TO THAT WORKS YES IT IS IT'S
ABSOLUTELY WORKING NIGHT WE HAVE
A PROVIDED DEEPER SUBSIDY FOR.
OF MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING OR
WON'T WE JUST WE JUST DID
APPROVE A PROJECT FOR IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE. THAT IS GOING
TO HAVE MIXED INCOME. AND A SET
ASIDE SPECIFICALLY FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND SO WHAT THEY DID
IS WHEN THEY CAME IN WITH THEIR
SUBSIDY AND THEY ALSO HAD SOME
OLD REDEVELOPMENT DOLLARS THAT
WERE IN THE PROJECT. THAT THEY
WANTED THAT THE PROJECT WANTED
TO HAVE RE SUBORDINATE
SUBORDINATED AND SO IN EXCHANGE
FOR THEM RE SUBORDINATING THAT
DEBT.
THEY GOT TEN PERCENT OF THE
UNITS SET ASIDE FOR HOMELESS AND
SO THERE ARE VERY CREATIVE AND
STRATEGIC WAYS IN WHICH YOU CAN
WORK WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND.
HAVING COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND NOW BEING WITH
THE STATE THAT I THINK THAT IS
SO CRITICAL THAT WE WORK
TOGETHER COLLABORATIVELY SO THAT
WE CAN ALIGN OUR RESOURCES AND
MAKE THOSE TYPE OF PROJECTS
HAVE.
YEAH I I.
WHO WHEN I WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER
RIGHT FOUNDED THE CITY'S HOUSING
DEPARTMENTS?
DID SAN JOSE SO SO WE.
WE THINK THAT THAT KIND OF
APPROACH WITH THE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
ESPECIALLY.
SIR ONCE WITH THE WHERE WITH.
TOO BLAND AND THEN THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE. FOR BOTH YOU
IS.
.
HOUSING TRUST OUT HOW I OF
HOUSING TRUST.
FUND PROGRAMS.
IT HAD SOME OF THE STATE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU HAVE IS THOSE
ARE THOSE.
UNITIES.
.
ACTIVATED.
AND THEY WILL BE ACTIVATED
HOPEFULLY WITH SP THREE BUT.
HOW HOW WOULD YOU USE A HOUSING
TRUST YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON?
HOUSING TRUST.
BETTER THERE'D BEEN CREATED SO
MANY COMMUNITIES.
YES WE WE OFTEN WILL WORK WITH
HOUSING TRUST FUNDS IN TERMS OF
THE THE FINANCING THAT THEY
PROVIDE. AND I WOULD SAY THERE
IS A SPECTRUM OF CAPACITY
EQUALITY AND CAPITALIZATION FOR
HOUSING TRUST FUNDS. BUT NOT ALL
OF THEM ARE EQUAL BY ANY MEANS
WE HAVE A NUMBER OUT THERE THAT
ARE ROUTINELY. A DEPLOYING THEIR
CAPITAL RELIEF TO HELP ACQUIRE
SITES THERE PROVIDING THE
CRITICAL SERVE SUBSIDY GAP OF
THE BRIDGES. WHAT A PROJECT IS
GETTING FROM FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS
PLUS THE STATE THEY GIVE THAT
DELTA? THE MAKE SOME COMPETITIVE
WHEN THEY COMMIT ARE PART OUR
PROGRAM TO PROCESSES.
TO MAKE EVEN MORE SO WITH THAT
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT.
HAVING LOST SOME OF ITS VALUE.
AND I THINK TWO THINGS AS WE
LOOK FORWARD THE REALLY
IMPORTANT THING ABOUT ONE IS.
OBVIOUSLY S. B. THREE DOES
PROVIDE FUNDS FOR US TO
INVESTIGATE AND IN DIRECTLY INTO
CAPITALIZING THESE REGIONAL
HOUSING TRUST FUND WILL BE
HUGELY HELPFUL.
I'M IN THE SECOND IS I THINK
WITH SP TWO WE WILL ALSO NOW FOR
THE FIRST TIME SEE.
FUNDING GOING DIRECTLY INTO A
LOT OF CITIES INCLUDING SOME
THAT MAY NOT HAVE HOUSING
APARTMENTS RIGHT THEY MAY NOT
ACTUALLY HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN
OPERATING A HOUSING PROGRAM. I
THINK WE HAVE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY BY THE COUNTY OR THE
CAN BE RE ETHANOL BILL WE HAVE
RARE OPPORTUNITY SORT HIM SUSE I
I THINK IT'S A GREAT VALUE
PROPOSITION FOR CITIES TO SORT
OF SAY HEY WE'RE GONNA BE
GETTING SOME S. B. TO MONEY FOR
THE FIRST. TIME SORTING TWENTY
EIGHT NINETEEN.
BUT MAYBE DOES MAKE SENSE FOR US
TO BUILD UP A DEPARTMENT AND
STAFF OF THE PROGRAMMES NOT
ENOUGH MONEY BUT IF WE CAN
CONTRACT THAT SERVICE WITHOUT
REASON HOUSING TRUST FUND IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE COUNTY.
PROVIDE NONPROFIT IT'S A WIN WIN
WIN.
THE OF THE.
O. ORGANIZATIONS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THAT.
ARE WRONG DESPERATE FOR HOUSING
THEY KEEP.
CALLING OUR OFFICES WANTING
HOUSING FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
ETCETERA. OF. A LOT OF THEM ARE.
IT THIS TIME TRYING TO INVEST
OR SUBSIDIZE THEIR EMPLOYEES.
IN TERMS OF ARM.
HOUSING.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE GIVING THEIR
EMPLOYEES STIPENDS AND VOUCHERS
AND.
THERE EVEN RENTING LARGE
SECTIONS OF APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
HOUSING THEIR EMPLOYEES.
IN THAT WAY.
IN ADDITION WE HEAR FROM THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT THEY WANT.
TEACHER HOUSING AND AND OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS.
OUR OUR.
.
ARE YOU OR YOUR AGENCIES.
I D. IS ON HOW TO USE.
NOT JUST THE OF FOCUSING ON S.
B. WANTED TO BUT. OR OR TWO OR
THREE BUT.
ANY.
FUNDS THAT WE COULD FIND.
ARE YOU ARE YOU.
ABLE TO USE THOSE FUNDS FOR
THOSE KINDS OF PURPOSES AND
COLLABORATION.
WITH SAY A SCHOOL DISTRICT OR.
.
PRIVATE EMPLOYER. TO HELP
SUBSIDIZE.
.
THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES.
I THINK IN A BROADER
APPLICATIONS AND WE'RE WE'RE
CURRENTLY USING
YEAH TECHNICAL ANSWERS THAT IT
DEPENDS.
BECAUSE WHILE WE CAN DEPLOY OUR
FUNDS AND ALSO POTENTIALLY
FEDERAL FUNDS THERE ARE SOME
LIMITATIONS THAT COME WITH
THOSE.
AND SO YOU REALLY SPICK ICY
SIDEWALK ON A COMMERCIAL ACTIONS
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT ALWAYS WORK
QUITE RIGHT FOR THE SALARIES AT
A GIVEN EMPLOYEE OR TEACHER MY
COMMUNITY.
AND WE ALSO HAVE TO HAVE THE
OBLIGATION OF THE FAIR HOUSING
ACT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE
HOPE THAT.
LEASING PRACTICES ARE ARE NOT.
ALRIGHT DISCRIMINATORY TERMS OF
WHO ENDS UP GETTING THE HOUSING
IS PROVIDED A STATE AND FEDERAL
MONEY SO WE CAN MAKE IT WORK.
BUT BUT IT DEPENDS ON FACT
PATTERN IMPRINT THAT WE DO WE DO
TAKE A POSITION TYPE TIME WE
DON'T WORK HAVE WORKED ON A
NUMBER SCHOOL SCHOOL
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS TO THIS
PANEL.
PERSON I WANT TO SEE AGAIN THANK
BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
MANY OF US TO.
WHO UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF A VERY INTENSE
CRISIS THAT HOPEFULLY BY WORKING
TOGETHER WILL BE ABLE TO?
TO GET THROUGH AND I'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO ALL THE
IMPLEMENTATION WORK YOU WERE
DOING THIS YEAR AND A PLEASE
KEEP US POSTED ON. BOTH HOW THAT
IS GOING AS WELL AS. WHAT WE CAN
DO TO KEEP OUR COMMON AGENDA
MOVING FORWARD AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE?
THE VERY PUBLIC OUTREACH THAT
BOTH YOUR AGENCIES ARE ENGAGED
IN WITH OUR KIDS.
SO THAT'S
MUCH APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT.
YEAH OK UM. WILL.
NEXT YEAR THE NEXT PANEL WHICH
IS.
WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME YOU COMING
HOW SHE TO COME FORWARD.
THIS IS LOCAL INNOVATIVE
EFFORTS TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS
AND.
S. PANEL WILL FOCUS ON STEPS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND OTHERS ARE TAKING TO TACKLE
HOMELESSNESS AND.
HOW UPDATED PLANNING DOCUMENTS
AND OTHER THINGS CAN BE USED TO?
SPEED UP OUR HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES SO WE HAVE.
WE HAVE.
.
ELAINE.
THE CALL A OKAY ELAINE GOTCHA.
SHE'S HERE LOU BROWN LOHR
ARCHER LE. A LOOP BROWN'S MERCED
COUNTY.
RIGHT LOOK.
MERCED GOOD.
.
LARA ACTUALIZED JAMBOREE.
HOUSING I.
BEEN HERE BEFORE.
OKAY WELL TURNED IT OVER TO YOU
WHAT WILL FIRST HEAR FROM
ELAINE.
WELCOME ELAINE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN BALLOT IN.
CHAIRMAN CHU ON ITS SIDE.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON AND SHARE WITH YOU
INSIGHTS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM EVERYONE HOMES DECADES
LONG.
WORK TO ENSURE EVERY RESIDENT OF
ALAMEDA HIGHS SO SAFE AFFORDABLE
HOME.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
MY ENTIRE CAREER AND I'LL ASK
YOU NOT TO DO ANY MATH HERE BUT
THAT'S CLOSE TO THIRTY YEARS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WORKING TO AND
HOMELESSNESS. REALLY GOOD AND SO
THAT MAKES ME. TWENTY FIVE.
.
AND I DID SO I I DIDN'T.
I AM VERY EXCITED BY THIS MOMENT
IN TIME FOR THIS STATE.
AND WHAT IT COULD MEAN FOR US TO
TURN THE CURVE ON HOMELESSNESS
IN THE HOUSING CRISIS.
BUT I THINK IT'S REALLY GONNA
TAKE SOME ATTENTIVE.
STRATEGIC.
I DESIGN OF
HOW THESE RESOURCES
GET USED.
SO FOR FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT
DON'T KNOW EVERYONE HOME WE
SERVICE ALAMEDA COUNTY'S
HOMELESS CONTINUUM OF CARE WHICH
IS A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT IN
ORDER TO GET FEDERAL DOLLARS AND
WE GOT ABOUT FORTY MILLION OF
THOSE.
AND WE ALSO SERVED AS THE
BACKBONE ORGANIZATION SUPPORTING
THE COUNTIES PLAN TO END
HOMELESSNESS AND ENSURE EVERYONE
HAS A SAFE PERMANENT HOME.
AND WE'VE BEEN ON IT FOR ABOUT
TEN YEARS AND ONE WE ADOPTED THE
PLAN TEN YEARS AGO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND ALL FOURTEEN OF
OUR CITIES.
OUR ADOPTED IT AND ONE OF THE
MAJOR STRATEGIES THAT CALLED FOR
WAS CREATING. MORE HOMES.
AND WE HAVE CREATED MORE HOMES
BUT LIKE THE REST OF THE STATE
NOT AT THE PACE NEEDED AND FOR
AWHILE. FOR THE FIRST EIGHT
YEARS WE SAW ARE HOMELESS COUNTS
GO DOWN THERE AND THEN TWO YEARS
AGO. ARE AYE BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN ARE COUNT INCREASED.
THIRTY NINE PERCENT.
AND DIE SOME OF THAT WAS OUR NEW
COUNT METHODOLOGY BUT IT WAS
LIKE THE REST OF THE STATE
MOSTLY ABOUT. HOMELESSNESS GOING
NOT.
ALSO IN MY COUNTY WERE FACING A
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND UNIT GAP
FOR.
ARE EXTREMELY LOW INCOME RENTERS
AND RENTS IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND
HAVE GONE UP AT THE FASTEST PACE
ARE IN THE NATION. EXCEPT ONE
OTHER DISTRICT.
AND DIED THEY'VE GONE UP FIFTY
PERCENT IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
SO HERE WE ARE WE'VE GOT.
BEAR AREA RESIDENTS IDENTIFYING
THE COST OF HOUSING IS THE
SINGLE. OUR MOST PRESSING CRISIS
AND INCREASING NUMBERS OF OUR
LIFELONG RESIDENTS ARE FORCED
OUT OF THEIR HOMES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND THOSE WHO CAN
MOVE EAST AND NORTH.
BUT THOSE WHO CANNOT.
JOIN THE GROWING POPULATION OF
WHAT I LIKE TO CALL SADLY
HOUSING REFUGEES.
LIVING IN ON SHELTERED ON THE
SIDEWALKS UNDERPASSES PARKS IN
ARROYO'S OF EVERY COMMUNITY IN
OUR COUNTY BUT.
ACROSS THE STATE AND THESE
INHUMANE CONDITIONS IN WHICH
PEOPLE ON THE STREET FACE DAILY
CALL US TO ADDRESS THIS HOUSING
CRISIS WITH.
CONTINUED SENSE OF URGENCY.
AND TO FOCUS ON THOSE AT THE
VERY BOTTOM OF THIS CRISIS.
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE STATE
WITH OUT A HOME ON ANY GIVEN
NIGHT.
WE HOT WE'VE REALLY NEED TO BE
THOUGHTFUL TO AVOID HAVING
TRICKLED DOWN HOUSING POLICIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE FREQUENTLY. PRESUME THAT
BUILDING HOUSING FOR ANYONE WILL
HELP ALL PEOPLE THAT NEED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
BUT I WANNA SORT TO YOU TODAY.
THAT MIDDLE INCOME AND
AFFORDABLE AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING WILL NOT SOLVE
HOMELESSNESS.
THE FOLKS WHO HAVE LOST THEIR
HOMES IN MARKETS WHERE RENTS
HAVE GONE OUT LIKE THE BAY AREA
WILL NOT GET BACK INTO HOMES
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE MIDDLE
INCOME HOMES.
IN THEIR REGIONS AND COUNTIES
NOT THAT MIDDLE INCOME HOMES ARE
A BAD THING.
BUT I THINK I KNOW THE VOTERS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHEN THEY PASSED
THAT FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR HOUSING BOND DID
IT THINKING THEY WERE ENDING
HOMELESSNESS.
SO WHAT I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO
THINK ABOUT WITH XP TWO IS
REALLY TARGETING THOSE
RESOURCES.
BUT WHEN YOU SAY THERE FOR
HOMELESS THE OTHER THING YOU
GOTTA DO IS STOP THE INFLOWS
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND INCREASE
THE OUT FLOWS FROM HOMELESSNESS.
IF WE BUILD MORE THINGS THAT
HELP PEOPLE LIVE MORE HUMANELY
BUT STAYED HOME ONCE.
LIKE SHELTERS ARE SANCTIONED
ENCAMPMENTS YOU WOULD JUST KEEP
HAVING MORE HOMELESS.
SO WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THESE S. B. TWO DOLLARS.
AND HOMELESSNESS
I AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO
SUPPORT THINGS THAT SHOW RESULTS
QUICKLY.
CHIEF GOT A NUMBER OF MAJOR
REGIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE BAY AREA HAS DONE
IT SANTA CLARA ALAMEDA SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE GOT BONDS.
AND WE'RE BUILDING UNITS NOW WE
CAN USE S. B. TO MONEY.
SUBSIDIZE THE RENTS IN THOSE
UNITS AND REQUIRED THE PEOPLE
THAT MOVED IN THERE HAVE BEEN
HOME.
IF YOU BUILDING YOU KNOW THAT
FIFTY PERCENT A ON MY NO ONE BIT
THAT'S BEEN HOMELESS WILL EVER
BE ABLE TO AFFORD THAT UNIT.
SIXTY PERCENT OF THE ADULTS WHO
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
ME TO COUNTY ARE ON DISABILITY.
AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
RAPID RE HOUSING IS A GOOD
STRATEGY BUT IT WON'T WORK FOR
THOSE FOLKS THEY WON'T EVER
AFFORD RANKS IN OUR MARKET.
SO FOR PAIN TO BUILD THESE UNITS
AND WE WANT THESE UNITS TO AND
HOMELESSNESS WE'VE GOTTA
SUBSIDIZE HOMELESS PEOPLE'S
ACCESS TO THESE UNITS. AND
YOU'VE GOT PROJECTS COMING
ONLINE WITH LOCAL BONDS AS SOON
AS THAT NO FOUR COMES OUT. YOU
COULD BUY YOUR WAY INTO HIM FOR
HER WITH HOPE BOB WITH SP TWO
DOLLARS FOR HOMELESS PEOPLE.
AND THAT IS REALLY THE CAO
PORCINE WE'VE DONE A LOT OF GOOD
WORK IN THE STATE AROUND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
BUT THE REAL GAP IS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE DIAZ TO.
POOR TO PAY THE RENT AND THEY'RE
ON FIXED INCOMES SO THEIR INCOME
ISN'T GOING TO CHANGE AND WE
COULD REALLY USE I SPEAK TO.
THERE.
THANK.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON NOTHING SIR
HAVE ME HERE APPRECIATE IT.
SENATOR.
BELLE AND SIR CHIU.
SO.
IN MY ABOUT BY ANY MAY NOTICE
I'M ACTUALLY FROM DETROIT
MICHIGAN.
I'M I'VE BEEN DOING THIS WORK I
JUST OVER TEN YEARS NOW.
SINCE THAT GRADUATING COLLEGE.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW RELOCATING TO
CALIFORNIA PASSED A FIVE MONTHS
MY WIFE IS FROM THE AREA MERCED
COUNTY.
AND ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT
HAPPENED WHEN WE.
MOVED HERE WAS THAT SHE BROKE
DOWN IN TEARS SING THE NUMBER OF
CODDLING HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
LIVING ON THE STREETS.
BECAUSE IT WASN'T THE HOME THAT
SHE HAD LAUGHED WHEN SHE MOVED
TO MICHIGAN.
AND SO HOME THROUGH THE IN
KNOWING MIKE SWINGS THE CHRONIC
HOMELESS THAT SHE'S LIKE YOU YOU
KNOW LOOK YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
AND.
WHICH KIND OF BRINGS US HERE DO
THINKING STRATEGICALLY ABOUT
HIGH SPEED TO AND HOW THIS IS
MOVING TOWARD SOLVING FOR
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
AND HOMELESSNESS HOME.
AND SO AND WHEN WORKING WITH
LOCAL. AND COMMUNITY SOMERSET
COUNTY THIS YEAR'S COUNT ACCESS
ON INCREASE AND I'M
HOMELESSNESS.
WHAT WE DO HAVE ACCESS TO
RAPIDLY HOUSING DOLLARS?
BUT WE HAVE A LACK OF OF
HOUSING IN GENERAL WE HAVE A ONE
PERCENT VACANCY RATE LESSEN UPS
AND WE CAN SEE RATE.
WHEN IT COMES TO APPLYING FOR
PERMITS.
WE HAVE.
FOR EVERY UNIT THAT ONE OF OUR
INDIVIDUALS APPLIES TO FOR
HOUSING HERE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS A COMPETING AGAINST
SEVENTY FIVE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
FOR THAT UNIT.
SO.
COMPETITIVELY THEY JUST CAN'T
COMPETE I'M SO DESPITE HAVING
RESOURCES WE YOU KNOW RAPPER
HOUSING TEAMS ARE UNABLE TO
HOUSE INDIVIDUALS.
SECONDLY THERE IS A LACK TO OF
OUTREACH WORKERS.
IN IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO WHEN DEALING WITH CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS.
I'M IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT YOU
KNOW THE ONE WHERE I REACHING
LEAVING THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
LOOKING FOR PLACEMENT HOUSING
THAT THEY'RE BEING LIED TO
COMMUNITY SERVICES.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SERVICES AND
THIS ISN'T MEANING JUST
INFORMATION REFERRAL THIS IS
LITERALLY TAKING THEM TO
APPOINTMENTS WALKING THEM
THROUGH SERVICES.
THE STEP BY STEP WITH THEM IN
PREPARATION FOR FOR HOUSING
AND BECAUSE IT JUST HOUSING
ALONE WILL NOT SOLVE THE ISSUE.
I'VE SUPERVISED MULTIPLE
PERMITS FOR SUPPORT HOUSING
PROJECTS IN IF THE SUPPORTS AND
HOUSING ARE EFFICIENT.
MORE LIKELY NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
WILL END UP BACK ON THE STREET
SO IT'S VERY IMPERATIVE THAT AN
SP TWO THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
AT THIS.
OPTION OF NOT ONLY BUILDING THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND MORE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WHICH IS DESPERATELY NEEDED.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS BUT
LOOKING AT THE SUPPORT SITE AN
ASPECT THINGS TO WITH STAFFING.
I'M FROM HOW REACH ANY IN INTO
HOUSING AS WELL.
.
AND SO. AND WITH THAT SIDE OF
SHELTER LOW BARRIERS FILTERS
VERY KEY TO.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT JUST A PLACE
FOR THEM TO GO AND STAY IT'S A
PLACE FROM TO GO AND SEE BEGAN.
YOU KNOW BEING CONNECTED TO
SERVICES TO FOR LONG TERM.
LONG TERM HOUSING OR PERMITS TO
BE PLACE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING
LONG TERM.
SO A PART OF THE BILL MISSIONS
AND NAVIGATION SINNERS.
AND SO I NOTICE THE SAN
FRANCISCO HAS DONE SOME NEW
BILLS. I'M FOR NAVIGATION
CENTERS THAT ARE INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE.
FOR OUR COMMUNITY I OVERSEE OUR
SHELTER OPERATIONS LOOKING AT
CHANGING OUR SHELTER STRUCTURES
AND HOW WE OPERATE WITHIN
COMMUNITIES TO MOVING TOWARDS.
AND NAVIGATION CENTER IS BEING
ABLE TO SAVE COSTS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
TO SPEND MORE OF THEIR DOLLARS
ON HOUSING AND WHAT SOME
BUILDING AND AT NEW CAPITAL ONE
BRICK AND MORTAR LIKING SHELTERS
AND NEW NAVIGATION CENTERS.
SO TAKING DOLLARS INITIALLY MAY
BE A FRY AYE LOW COST INVESTING
IN OUR SHELTERS AND RESEARCHING
HOW THEY OPERATE AND INVEST MORE
MONEY. LONG TERM FOR HOUSING.
AS KIND OF WHAT WE KNOW WE'RE
THINKING WOULD WORK FOR OUR OUR
COMMUNITY COMMITTEE LOCALLY.
BUT.
IF YOU KNOW LARA.
GREAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY. AREA.
BETTER. HAVE I'D LIKE TO START
FIRST BY THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
CONGRATULATE YOU FOR THE SUCCESS
IN MOVING THE HOUSING PACKAGE
FORWARD LAST YEAR. IS ABOUT SIX
MONTHS AGO OR SO THAT I WAS I'M
HERE TESTIFYING IN SACRAMENTO
I'M SO HAPPY THAT SOME ACTION
WAS TAKEN. AND I WERE READY TO
GO TO PRODUCE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AT JAMBOREE WE TAKE
FULL ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF THE
FUNDING PROGRAMS AVAILABLE HERE
UP AT THE STATE. AND THAT'S
HELPED US PRODUCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR FAMILY SENIORS. AND
THOSE WHO ARE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS LIVING WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS INCLUDING OUR VETERANS AND
OTHERS.
WE OPEN THE FIRST DEVELOPMENT
USING THE CAP AND TRADE FUNDING
JUST.
HERE IN WEST SACRAMENTO NOT TOO
FAR AWAY AND YEARS BACK WE OPEN
THE FIRST.
PERMITS PORT OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT FUNDED WITH THE
HOMELESS GOVERNOR'S HOMELESS
INITIATIVE FUNDING.
I SO AGAIN WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT WHAT'S TO COME.
JAMBOREE WAS AN ACTIVE RECIPIENT
OF THE REDEVELOPMENT FUNDING
WITH AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT OF
SUBSIDY WHICH PRODUCE STAR OVER
EIGHT THOUSAND UNITS IN OUR
PORTFOLIO. WE NOW HAVE OVER
SIXTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
THAT LIVE IN OUR PROPERTIES.
BECAUSE OF A COMBINATION OF
THESE FUNDING SOURCES.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT THE LOSS OF
REDEVELOPMENT OFTENTIMES PEOPLE
SAY C'MON WHERE YOU GOTTA MOVE
ON FROM THIS YOU KNOW IT WAS
QUITE AWHILE AGO NOW BUT. ONE OF
THE SIDE AND SIDE NOTES TO THE
ELIMINATION OF REDEVELOPMENT
UNFORTUNATELY WAS A COUPLE
THINGS.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT AS YOUR
WHERE THE HOUSING ELEMENT ONLY
REQUIRES YOU TO PLAN FOR HOUSING
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE YOU TO BUILD
IT. THE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS ACTUALLY
REQUIRED YOU TO BUILD IT SO
THINK ABOUT THAT NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IF YOU DIDN'T
BUILD THE HAVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. YOU COULD NOT BRING IN
THE BIG BOX RETAILERS YOU
COULDN'T BRING IN THE AUTO
MALLS.
RIGHT AND SO A DIRECT
CORRELATION TO THAT REDUCTION OF
TAX REVENUES COMING INTO THAT
JURISDICTION.
SO THAT CAUSED THEM TO MAKE SURE
MANY MOST
EXCEPT FOR THE REAL BAD BOYS BUT
MOST OF THEM TO PRODUCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND THAT'S
ELIMINATED ALONG WITH THAT WAS
MANY OF THE STAFF THAT WORKED IN
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS EITHER
RETIRED WERE LAID OFF OR REMOVE
TOGETHER TO OTHER POSITIONS SO.
WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS WE HAVE MANY
CITIES THAT OF COURSE NO LONGER
HAVE FUNDING THEY NO LONGER HAVE
LAND? AND THEY NO LONGER HAVE
STAFF THAT EDUCATED IN THIS IS
KIND OF TAKING ME TO THE S. B.
TO. I'M OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION SO EDUCATING
THE NEW STAFF THAT ARE COMING IN
ON HOW TO GET AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS PRODUCED. EVEN
THOSE WHO MIGHT OF TOUCH DID IN
THE PAST DID ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES RIGHT IS AT THE TIME THEY
HAD LAND THEY COULD GO OUT FOR
AN RFP THEY COULD PUT TOGETHER
THE LAYERS OF FINANCING. THE WAY
THEY WANTED IT TO IT'S MUCH
DIFFERENT NOW FOR JAMBOREE WILL
WORK GOING OUT WERE ACTUALLY
HAVING TO TIE UP LAND.
OFTENTIMES TAKE IT DOWN EARLY
GET BRIDGE FINANCING WORKING AND
TOTALLY NEW DIFFERENT WAYS OF
FINANCING ARE PROJECTS. THAT WE
DID IN THE PAST AND SO I THINK
THAT AND IT WOULD BE VERY VERY
HELPFUL FOR THE SP TWO FUNDING
THAT'S GOING TO THE LOCAL LEVELS
TO OF COURSE.
AND.
WORK WITH THOSE JURISDICTIONS ON
UPDATING THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT
THERE'S STONING CODES ALL OF THE
TECHNICAL. AND PROGRAMS NEEDED
TO MOVE HOUSING FORWARD BUT ALSO
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. TO DO
JUST GENERAL EDUCATION SO SEVEN
YEARS AGO WHEN WE FINANCED THE
FIRST PERMITS PART OF HOUSING.
I'M PROJECT THERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE DID TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF OUTREACH INITIALLY THE
PROJECT WAS TURNED DOWN IT WAS
THE MOST HORRIFIC PUBLIC.
HEARING I'D EVER BEEN OUT WERE
ALL KINDS OF MISINFORMATION WAS
SPREAD ABOUT THE CHILD MOLESTERS
WHO WERE GOING TO BE LIVING AT
THE PROPERTY. WE HAD CHILDREN
STAND UP AT THE MICROPHONE AND
THEN KURT PRINGLE WAS MAYOR SOME
OF YOU KNOW KURT. AND SAY TO
HIM.
PLEASE DON'T PUT THESE FOLKS IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND IT TOOK SO
MUCH EDUCATION AND FINALLY HE
SAID OR YOU GOTTA BRING THE
PROJECT BACK WERE READY TO FUND
THE PROJECT WE FUNDED IT NOW
FLASH FORWARD. SEVEN YEARS LATER
AND I HAD THE ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER IN THAT SAME CITY SAY TO
ME. SO YOU'RE REALLY GONNA PUT
PEOPLE LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND THAT PROPERTY AND IS
THAT GOING TO BE OKAY.
RIGHT AND IT WAS JUST A FLASH
RIGHT NOW I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR A LONG TIME GREAT. AND I
THOUGHT SO AGAIN WE HAVE TO DO
TOWARDS WE HAVE TO EDUCATE AND
SO I THINK IF YOU GO BACK TO
THAT SPEAK TO FUNDING. ALLOWING
STAFF TO USE THOSE FUNDS TO
EDUCATE THE NEW COUNCIL PEOPLE
WHO OF COMMENT AND THE NEW
SENIOR STAFF WHO ARE MAKING
DECISIONS AND I NEED TO HAVE THE
COURAGE TO MOVE FORWARD.
WE'RE WORKING IN ONE CITY RIGHT
NOW AND I NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
THAT JUST DECLARED AN EMERGENCY
AND YOU MIGHT BE SEEN THE CITIES
ARE DECLARING AN EMERGENCY FOR
THE HOMELESS ISSUES YOU SEE ON
TV IN ORANGE COUNTY. THEY'RE
CLEARING THE RIVER BEDS AND THE
JUDGE CAME IN NEGOTIATED THE
DEAL WHERE THEY WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO REMOVE THE.
HOMELESS FOLKS.
FROM THE RIVER BAD IF THEY WOULD
PROVIDE A HOUSING VOUCHER A
THIRTY DAY HOUSING VOUCHERS.
WHAT IS SO IRONIC IN THIS
SITUATION THIS IS THE CITY THAT
WE RIGHT NOW HAVE A MOTEL UNDER
CONTRACT WERE ATTEMPTING TO
CONVERT IT FROM ME?
RUN DOWN MOTEL INTO.
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT OF
THREE HAVE INTO A BEAUTIFUL
PERMITS PART OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT ALL KINDS OF.
IMPACTFUL RESIDENTS SERVICES IN
THE SAME COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE
TELLING US IT'S GONNA TAKE THREE
YEARS BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN
OUTDATED ZONING ORDINANCE. AND
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
GENERAL PLAN AMENDMENT AND THEY
HAVE TO WE HAVE TO DO THE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH AND I SAID TO
THE.
THE LEAD STAFF
FOLKS YOU DO REALIZE THAT FOLKS
ARE BEING RELOCATED INTO THOSE
MOTELS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE NOT
BEING FIXED UP. THAT ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO STAY LONGER
THAN THIRTY DAYS BECAUSE AS THE
JUDGE REALLY GOING AND THEN JUST
ALLOW THEM TO GO ON TO THE
STREET A MEMBER TALK ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE.
SO ANYWAYS THERE'D IS A CRISIS
I'M EXCITED THAT THERE'S GONNA
BE FUNDING COMING FORWARD I
THINK THAT THERE'S. THE MOST.
FLEXIBILITY WE CAN HAVE IN THE
USE OF HOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
USE THAT EDUCATE AND INFORM.
TOURS STATEWIDE TORS TO TRY TO
EASE ANY FEAR THAT PEOPLE HAVE I
THINK WOULD BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL.
AND.
.
I THINK IT JUST SOME COMMENTS ON
THE FAIR SHARE ISSUE ON WHO'S
GETTING WHAT IF YOU CAN LOOK TO
YOUR. FIVE YEAR GOOD USERS IN
TERMS OF THOSE CITIES THAT KNOW
HOW TO DO IT KNOW HOW TO GET IT
DONE. IT.
OF RUNNING A NONPROFIT BUT A
BUSINESS OBVIOUSLY AT JAMBOREE
WE'VE HAD TO DO THAT YOU CAN'T
STAY IN BUSINESS IF YOU'RE JUST
GONNA KEEP. GOING UP AGAINST THE
CITY THAT'S NEVER GOING TO GO
ANYWHERE AND.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WE SAW THAT
WITH SOME REDEVELOPMENT WERE
SOME CITIES DIDN'T SPEND THEIR
MONEY. AND THEN.
AGAIN PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING REALLY BEING THE ANSWER.
VERSE SAYS.
SPENDING MONEY ON OTHER
ALTERNATIVES WHICH DO NOT GET US
THE END PRODUCT LIKE WE'RE
SEEING WITH THESE MOTEL
VOUCHERS.
SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME OF THANK YOU THREE
PANELISTS INTO.
YOU KNOW.
.
YOU KNOW YOU TALK TO ABOUT IT
SPEAK TO WIN THAT'S
WE SAW HOW.
THE HOUSING DEPARTMENT.
BUT.
.
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT TO
EIGHTEEN IN THE NEXT PANEL BY
CASH TO.
.
SUPPOSE SO.
THE HOUSE THERE IS IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THERE ALL COUNTY
HERE BUNCH OF US.
GOT TOGETHER AND WE GOT SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDS OUT OF THE
SURPLUS TO STATE HOUSE.
HOW HOW QUICKLY CAN THAT MONEY
BE USED?
AND WHAT WOULD YOU YOU JUST
OUTLINED FOR.
WELL I YEAH SO I KNEW.
COULD YOU WOULD HELP US GET.
YEAH  ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM
OTHER SOURCES AND BE. WOULD IT
HELP.
GOVERNMENT SO COSTS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
BE REDUCED WRITTEN WELL AB I IN
I BELIEVE ABSOLUTELY THAT
WHATEVER FUNDING COULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE IMMEDIATELY. AS IN THE
JOURNAL WHICH
COULD PUT BE PUT DIRECTLY INTO
PROJECTS VERY QUICKLY SO GIVEN
THE ORANGE COUNTY EXAMPLE THAT'S
WHERE OUR HEADQUARTERS ARE SO I
I SPEAK TO THAT MOST. IS WE'VE
GOT.
RIGHT NOW TWELVE HUNDRED UNITS
IN OUR DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS TO TRY TO FREE UP.
ALL THE FUNDING THAT THEY HAVE
BECAUSE THAT WE KNOW IT'S IT'S
WE'RE GONNA MAX THAT OUT.
I ALONG WITH ALL OF THEIR
VOUCHERS
TO TRY A GET THAT HOUSING
PRODUCED RIGHT AWAY WORKING WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AN AC CO SEE. DOWN THERE WITH
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHAT WE
DID WAS WE TOOK IS ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND IN THE COUNT IN ORANGE
COUNTY. SO WE'VE TAKEN THAT
WE'VE DIVIDED THAT BY CITIES SO
THAT CITIES DON'T FEEL THAT
THEY'RE TAKING MORE THAN THEIR
FAIR SHARE BECAUSE THAT'S AN
ISSUE WHEN YOU'RE WORKING WITH
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND
WE'VE DIVIDED THAT HAPPEN IF
SAID CAN YOU GIVE US A
COMMITMENT CAN YOU TALK TO US
ABOUT SITES.
WE JAMBOREE PUSHING TO GET AHEAD
OF THIS WE HAVE THE SITES TIED
UP AGAIN FOR ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED UNITS AND WE'RE READY TO
GO SO EVERY. THREE TO FOUR
MONTHS OUR PLAN IS TO START
APPLYING FOR FUNDING FROM THE
COUNTY YEAH STATE FUNDING COMES
OUT WILL COME RIGHT INTO THE
STATE AND THEN GETTING INTO. A
TAX CREDIT ROUND OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH NINE
PERCENT TAX CREDITS TO FUND THIS
SO WE HAVE A BOND AND FOUR
PERCENT MODEL THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON. WHICH YOU KNOW IS KIND OF
WHERE THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
HAS GONE WHICH IS A NICE
SUPPLEMENT TO THAT PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD WORK IF SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WAS AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY WE COULD. START
GETTING SOME OF THE BOND AND
FOUR PERCENT PROJECTS MOVING I
THINK THE LAND AS.
LUKE YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT.
HOUSING WHERE IT'S.
SERVICES AND THE HOUSING.
HOW WOULD WE DO THAT? YOU KNOW
LIKE I LOOK AT.
META CAO.
THERE'S.
LET FIFTEEN WAIVER YOU KNOW
THAT ALLOWS.
SOME MEDICAL SERVICES TO BE PUT.
BLENDED WITH.
I THINK IT'S ELEVEN FIFTEEN
WHERE I AM RIGHT.
YEAH ALLOWS THE BLENDING OF THE
MEDI CAL SERVICES IN A HOUSING
PROJECT TO HIRE LIKE A SOCIAL
PSYCHIATRIC SOCIAL WORKERS.
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW MEDICAL STAFF
EXETER A TO PROVIDE.
DE.
SERVICES IN THOSE.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
.
AND.
HOW WOULD YOU IF IF THERE WERE
THESE KIND OF FUNDS HOW WITH AB
HOW WOULD THAT WORK? IS ANYBODY
DON'T ALLOW THAT KIND OF THING
SO ALAMEDA COUNTY IS IS EXILE
AND RELIEVE ROPE ROWING OUT.
.
BIG IT WHAT WERE LIKE WE HAVE
LAUNCHED COORDINATED ENTRY WERE
USING A WHOLE PERSON CARE
DOLLARS WHICH INCLUDED THAT.
AT THE MEDICARE WAIVER.
I IN IN ORDER TO GENERATE MONEY
YEAH YEAH.
SINCE BALLOTS OTHERWISE
SHRINKING.
IT'S GOOD TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
IT SO WE WE HAVE ABOUT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS GOING INTO
SUPPORTING CARE COORDINATION AND
COORDINATED AND TREE AND.
BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT ABOUT MONEY
TRIES OFTEN IN ANOTHER THREE
YEARS.
SO I I. GOT THAT BRINGS ME TO.
A POINT I WAS GETTING TOO FIRED
UP TO MAKE IN MY EARLIER REMARKS
ABOUT S. B. TWO I KNOW THE FIRST
YEAR IS DEDICATED TO
HOMELESSNESS BUT I THINK THE
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN LOOK AT.
ONGOING FUNDING AND
INCENTIVIZING OR BURKE BOARDING
AND I'M GOING COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS LIKE.
SOMETHING WE JUST DO ONE YEAR
REALLY ISN'T GONNA SAVAGE PEOPLE
NEED I'M GOING DEEP SUPPORT TO
TO STAY HOUSED IN CALIFORNIA'S
MARKET SO. I AT WHICH ALSO DOWN
THERE POINT I WANTED TO MAKE
ABOUT THAT I KNOW KIND OF THE
FASTEST PATH TO GETTING THE
MONEY OUT THE DOOR FROM STATE H.
CD. IS TO FOLLOW THE.
ESG PROGRAM DESIGN BUT THAT
DOESN'T REALLY ALLOW FOR
PERMANENT SUBSIDIES AND SUPPORT
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY WHERE
THE CAPTAINS COULD DO.
THESE HOUSING TRUST.
THEY HAVE ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY
ARE POLL OF STUFF TOGETHER ARE I
THINK THE ONE THING I DON'T NEED
A COUNTY IS THE CAPITAL. ITS
CAPITAL SO I THINK THAT I THINK
THAT WITH THE COUNTY.
CAP THE CAPITAL.
I'M SURE HOUSING TRUST IN AND
THEIR OPERATING.
THE COUNTY CAN WORK OUT THE
BLENDS.
OF FROM.
AYE I THINK SO BUT I THINK THAT
I THINK THAT IF THE I THINK IT
THE STATE KEEPS SP TWO FLEXIBLE
TO COMPROMISE OPERATING RESERVES
AND IF YOU GET THE NEW MONEY
WITH A IS IT TO EIGHTEEN YOU SAT
DOWN. AND AND AGAIN I THINK
YOU'VE GOT REGION'S THAT HOBBES
STUFF IN THE PIPELINE BECAUSE OF
THEIR LOCAL BOND MEASURES.
AND AND SO REALLY GETTING THOSE
ACROSS THE LINE DEVELOPMENT WISE
WAR GETTING GETTING ACCESS FOR
THE EXTREMELY LOW INCOME FOLKS
INTO THOSE BUILDINGS ARE ZERO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SO FEDERAL MONEY
NOW THE CURES ACT.
.
HOW'S THAT. DOES THAT COME INTO
PLAY HERE WITH HOMELESS.
PROGRAM SO WE CAN PUT.
.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE LE.
TREATMENT.
.
MONEY OF FEDERAL MONEY AND
THERE'S MORE FEDERAL MONEY FIRST
SERVICES MONEY CLEAN YOU KNOW
WE.
WE YEAH WE'RE LOSING SEATED BJ
WERE LOSING ALL YOU KNOW WE'RE
WHERE WE GOT THE BUDGET CUT BUT
THEN THEY LEFT SOME OF THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS. THAT WE HAVE TO
START. WE.
FOCUS SAYING.
EVERYTHING TO OR WHATEVER MONEY
IS LEFT THE.
AND AND I I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
YOU AND I THINK WE CAN SUPPORT
THE YOU MIGHT HAVE A CA THAT WAY
I'M GOING GOV ACCORDING TO
SUDHIR MOHAN. YEAH.
I THINK COUNTY SUPERVISOR LEVEL
ADVANCEMENT SERVICES. THERE ARE
SERVICES DOLLARS WE NEED SOME
BUT THEY'RE MORE AVAILABLE I
REALLY THINK IT'S OPERATING
COSTS THAT THE STATE COULD HELP
SUPPORT FOR THIS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO IT IS MORE AFFORDABLE
TO THE POOREST TALK TO STAY PUT
OUT SOME KIND OF.
TICE MINT IF YOU WANT YEAH THAT
WAY YEAH FOR.
COUNTIES THAT WILL HAVE LIKE
IT'S AFFORDABLE.
THEY CAN DO THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE COULD WE COULD.
DO OUR HOUSING FUNDS AND THEN.
PUT SOME ENTICEMENT.
ARE.
HEALTHCARE DOLLARS HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES DOLLARS ON THE TABLE.
YEAH WELL BEYOND THAT WOULD LOOK
GOOD TO THE COUNTIES AND THEY'D.
YES I THINK THE GREAT YEAH I
DON'T HELP ABSOLUTELY. AND WERE
SEEN A TARGET FOR BATTERED WOMEN
SUBSTANCE ABUSE MENTAL HEALTH.
THOUGH.
.
DOUBLE TRIPLE CHO PURGING
DISORDERS YOU TRY LE.
PSYCHIATRIC.
DUH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT HOMELESS
WALKING AROUND THERE REALLY
DEVELOP THE DISABLED THEY HAVE
BRAIN DAMAGE THE.
YOU KNOW LIKE YOU SAY THEY DO
SHOULD BE ON SS I WE SHOULD TRY
TO GIVE ALL.
SOME OF MARK ON SS I WISH TO GET
ON A SOCIETY SHOULD GET FOOD
STAMPS OR NOT ON FOOD STAMPS.
I MEAN THEY'RE NOT GETTING ALL
THIS FEDERAL.
STUFF THAT YOU KNOW IF THEY WERE
HOMELESS THAT WE'D GOOD.
WE HAD HOUSING WE CAN HAVE THE
SOCIAL WORKERS.
FOR ANY NOT OUT ALTOGETHER
EXACTLY AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING WITH THE PERMITS PART
OF HOUSING IN HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WITH HOTEL BURIAL. HUGO BY HOTEL
BARRY WE WERE ABLE TO PURCHASE
THAT WITH US A TURN REYES HELP.
PUT I'M HOMELESS FOLKS IN THERE
WHO REALLY HAD NO INCOME BUT
OVER TIME YOU FIGURE OUT THERE
ELIGIBLE THEIR INCOME JUSTICE A
GREAT NOW WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
VETERANS IN THERE. WERE ABLE TO
GET RESOURCES FOR THAT
OBSERVANCE.
IN THE CENTER THERE HAVE TO
VETERANS.
ARE NOT THERE HOMELESS HAVE TO
VETERANS TOTAL THAT HER. THAT
HER ELIGIBLE.
FOR VETERANS A MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE ARE NOT GETTING IT IN
CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THAT THE
MONEY THAT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
FORGET THEY'RE NOT GETTING IT.
SO SO LIKE THEN AND THAT AND I
KNOW THE SNAP PROGRAM THE FOOD
STAMP PROGRAM SIMPLY. IS ALWAYS
PEOPLE WALK AROUND THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE. THERE ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
NOT GETTING INTO.
THAT'S MONEY FOR YOUR. RIGHT AND
WHAT WE SEE WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING IT IS MEASURING THE FOLKS
WHO ARE IN OUR FIFTY TO SIXTY
PERCENT AND MY UNITS WHO GO OFF
OF THE FOOD. SUBSIDY PROGRAMS
HOW MUCH THAT SAVING GOVERNMENT
AND THEN IF YOU JUST ADJUST THAT
SO THAT THEN IT SERVING THOSE
WHO WERE AT THE STRIP
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME. WHO HAVE?
THE DISABILITIES THEN YOU'RE
ADJUSTING IT THE RIGHT WAY.
WE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY ON FOOD
IN THE COUNTY JAIL ON THE.
STATE PRISON THE FOOD IS ALL
HUNDRED PERCENT FUNDED BY THE.
THE COUNTY OR THE STATE GENERAL
FUND IT'S THERE'S NO FEDERAL
SUBSIDY THERE.
YEAH WELL I ERA SO.
STATE FUNDED FOOD AND ALL. YEAH
SO I'VE ALWAYS KINDA LAUGHED AT
THIS YOU KNOW SLICK.
WE WERE WE WHERE FULLER WERE
INSANE IN TERMS OF THE WAY WE.
TRY TO DO PROGRAMS.
DOESN'T WORK WHAT'S WRONG WITH
BUILT ON THIS HOUSING BUILDING
REBUILDING AND PRISONS.
THAT'S THAT WAS THE DISCUSSION
IN ORANGE COUNTY WHEN THEY CLEAR
THE RIVER BEDS WITH OKAY HOW
MANY PEOPLE WERE EARLY RELEASE
WHILE THE REALITY IS. YOU WANT
TO PAY TO HOUSE THEM IN THE. IN
THE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM READY
WANT TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR MY
HOUSING AND. AND GETTING ON THAT
THE CARE THAT THEY NEED FOR.
SO A FEW QUESTIONS FIRST ARE
COMMENTED TO MISS OUR CHILDREN.
UP I APPRECIATE YOUR SHARING THE
STORY OF HOW IT IT'S TAKEN THREE
YEARS TO BUILD UP PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SITE.
I'VE A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
CONTINUE TO FURTHER STREAMLINE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BECAUSE WE
ARE HEARING FROM ORGANIZATIONS
AT THAT THREE YEAR MARK IS
ACTUALLY FAIRLY TYPICAL. STORY
AND THAT IS OBVIOUSLY
UNACCEPTABLE WITH HOW MUCH MONEY
OR TRY TO GET OUT TO US TO
LOCALS TO DO THIS BUT THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE A REALLY
FOR.
MS THE COLONY IN AND ALSO MISS.
MISS ARCHULETA.
I THINK I HEARD.
MISS OUR CHIU IT YOU SAY THAT.
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY IS IS IS MOST
HELPFUL AT THIS POINT GETTING
MONEY OUT TO LOCALS IN ALLOWING
LOCALS TO TO.
APPLY THAT MONEY IS USE BEST SEE
FIT TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IS
IMPORTANT WHAT I HEARD EARLIER.
Y. SAID.
THERE IS A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
OF THOUGHT THAT WE'VE BEEN
WASTING MONIES.
SPENDING IT IN THE WRONG PLACES
AND THAT WHAT WE REALLY OUGHT TO
FOCUS ON.
TO TO TO.
ECHO WHAT.
MS.
.
MY APOLOGIES BOTH YOUR NAMES
LOCALES. DE COLLINI.
THE LANE LOWER THAT MIGHT BE
EASIER. BUT ALAIN YOUR COMMENTS
WHAT YOU WOULD SET WAS IF WE
STOP PEOPLE FROM BECOMING
HOMELESS
AND THEN FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP
FOLKS WERE ON THE RULES TO GET
OFF THAT'S REALLY WHERE WE OUGHT
TO FOCUS OUR OUR DOLLARS AND. I
WANTED TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE TWO OF
YOU.
THOSE TWO THAT DOES SEEM TO BE
TWO SCHOOLS OF THOUGHTS I MEAN
I'LL TELL YOU I COME FROM A
CITY.
THAT HAS SPENT CLOSE TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
TRYING TO ADDRESS HE FIVE TO
SEVEN THOUSAND. HOMELESS FOLKS
IN ANY PARTICULAR.
TIME AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE IT DEBT AND SO.
A IT SEEMS TO SUGGEST WE'RE NOT
DOING SOMETHING RIGHT WITH HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO SPEND OUR
MONIES.
AND MY GUESS IS AROUND STATE WE
SPENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TRYING
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IN ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT FORMS.
ARE AND REALLY STRUGGLING DOING.
ALL THAT BEING SAID I THINK WE
HAVE TO SPEND MORE BUT I WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE SPENDING. IN THE
RIGHT WAY SO COULD THE TWO OF
YOU.
TEASE OUT THAT.
ARGUMENT I'M HEARING FROM
DIFFERENT QUARTERS OF HOW WE AS
POLICY MAKERS OUGHT TO THINK
ABOUT. HOW MONIES ARE SPENT?
WHAT I I? REALLY WE'RE JUST
UPDATING OUR TEN YEAR PLAN SO
I'VE I'VE BEEN DOING SOME
ANALYSIS ON THAT INFLOWS INTO
HOMELESSNESS SO THAT. THE MOST
ACCURATE DATA POINT WE ALL HAVE
THIS THE POINT TIME COUNT WHEN
WERE WONDERING IF STREETS OF OUR
COUNTIES DISTRICTS.
LOOKING FOR FOLKS SLEEPING
OUTSIDE.
BUT WE ASK THE FOLKS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY HOW LONG THEY BEEN
HOMELESS IN TWO PERCENT OF THEM
OUT OF THE TWELVE HUNDRED WE
SURVEYED. SAID A WEAKER LASS SO
WE MULTIPLY THAT TIMES FIFTY TWO
WEEKS
AND ALMOST AS MANY PEOPLE NOW
WITH A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
PEOPLE BECOMING HOMELESS EACH
WEEK.
IN OUR COUNTY.
AND THE HOUSE FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE YEARS THAT'S THEIR FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS THAT'S
THE SAME NUMBER WE COUNTED ON
THAT ONE GIVE THE NINE.
SO IT'S IT MONEY STOP. AND SO.
YOU KNOW WERE WERE PULLING THE
BABIES OUT OF THE RIVER AND NO
ONE'S GOING UPSTREAM TO SEE
WHO'S THROWING BABIES IN THE
RECORD BREAKING WERE BUILDING
FANCIER BOATS AND FAST
APPROACHING MORE EXPENSIVE BUT
TO GET IN THE WATER FOR THE
BABY'S GETTING THROWN INTO THE
PEOPLE ON THE STREET. SO YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN ALAMEDA COUNTY
IS.
HOUSING A COUPLE THOUSAND FOLKS
A YEAR BUT WE'RE NOT KEEPING UP
WITH THAT LEVEL OF. IMPORT SO I
DO YOU REALLY THINK LOOKING AT.
SO. I'M GOING TO TOUCH A THIRD
RAIL HERE BUT I THINK COSTA
HAWKINS
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT TO.
I'M THINKING ABOUT REPEALING IT
SAID THAT TALK ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL. LOCAL FLEXIBILITY AND
RENDER PROTECTIONS BECAUSE WE
ARE JUST KICKING PEOPLE OUT OF
RENTAL HOUSING IN OUR COUNTIES
FROM BECAUSE FREEZING FROM
CONVERSION. AND DISPLACEMENT AND
WERE NOT BUILDING ENOUGH A
PUBLICLY FUNDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SAID THE PRIVATE MARKET
IS JUST KICKING PEOPLE INTO
HOMELESSNESS SO WE CANNOT. WE
GOT TO TAKE SOME ACTION TO
STABILIZE THAT.
PRIVATE MARKETS I WOULD SAY
BECAUSE THEY ARE A DEFINITE.
SOURCE FOR PEOPLE BECOMING
HOMELESS AND THEN I THINK WE CAN
TAKE SOME ACTIONS IN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FIELD TO HELP SUBSIDIZE IT MORE
DEEPLY SO THAT REALLY POOR
PEOPLE CAN GET INTO THE UNITS
WERE SPENDING PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
BAIL AND. SO I'M I'M NOT SURE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT
THINGS HERE I JUST I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE SAYING THAT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
HAVE THE COSTS THEY HAVE.
IT COSTS A THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
RUN THE UNIT IN THESE. URBAN
MARKETS AND A PERSON ON SS I CAN
ONLY AFFORD TO PAY THREE HUNDRED
SO WE'VE GOT TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE.
YEAH I MEAN I'VE.
FOCUS WILL ALWAYS BE ON
PRODUCTION BECAUSE I THINK WHERE
EVER YOU ARE AT THE MORE UNITS
IN THE MORE CHOICE YOU HAVE THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE.
APPLY DEMAND COMING INTO PLACE
BUT I THINK WHEN YOU GET TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE THOSE WHO ARE
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES. THOSE
IN THE EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
CATEGORY THAT CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS.
I THINK IT GETS AWFULLY TOUGH.
TO WORK TO KEEP THEM IN UNITS
WITH OUT FULL SUPPORT OF
SERVICES AND MAYBE THAT'S IT YOU
KNOW IN IMPLEMENTATION. BY I
WOULD. I DEFINITELY THINK THAT.
LOOKING AT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GIVING THEM THE MOST FLEXIBILITY
AND MAYBE SOME OF THE FUNDING
THAT THEY GET CAN BE USED WE HAD
WHEN I WENT CITY I WORKED FOR
HAD A. EMERGENCY GRANT PROGRAM
FOR ONE FOR ONE MONTH RIGHT SO
IF ONE MONTH.
BRENT AND THERE HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE AWAY FROM ONE PAYCHECK FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS RIGHT. IT IN
THIS MARKET RIGHT NOW SO MAYBE
THAT'S A PROGRAM THAT COULD BE
FUNDED BUT IT'S STILL NOT GOING
TO CURE THE CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
THE NEEDY OF THE NEEDY BUT MAYBE
IT STOP SO. WE DID THE POINT A
TIME COUNT IN ORANGE COUNTY WE
HAD. COME UP WITH AROUND FIVE
THOUSAND HALF OF THOSE FOLKS
WERE FOLKS THAT WERE HOMELESS
BECAUSE THEY RECENTLY LOST A
JOB.
THEY HAD A FAMILY TRAGEDY EVENT
SOMEBODY GOT SICK OR THERE WAS
ON A MARRIAGE THAT SPLIT UP SO
SOMEBODY WAS HOMELESS. THOSE ARE
FOLKS THAT SHOULD BE HOUSED
IN POTENTIALLY LIKE IT OUR
TRADITIONAL TAX CREDIT PROJECT
THEY'RE NOT THE MOST DIFFICULT
PEOPLE SO THEN THEN YOU ARE LEFT
WITH THE OTHER HALF. THAT ARE
GONNA BE YEAR MORE INTENSE
THAT. AGAIN NEED THE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ON SITE
EXACTLY DAYS TALKING ABOUT AND
WE'VE GOT A COMMITMENT ACTUALLY
FROM OUR. LARGE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM DOWN SOUTH TO PROVIDE
SERVICES ON SITE THEY BELIEVE
THERE'S ENOUGH BILL BACK
PROGRAMS TO COVER THOSE
SERVICES.
THAT WE'RE NOT UNDERWRITING IT
IN OUR PERFORMING IN OUR
OPERATING STANDARD SO YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ONE SILVER
BULLET BUT I THINK IF YOU CAN.
I'M PUT ANY PROGRAM INTO PLACE
TO PREVENT.
I'M HOMELESSNESS THE EVICTIONS
AND WE'VE ALL NOW I'M SURE READ
THAT A CONVICTED AND YOU READ
ABOUT WHAT IT DOES TO FAMILIES
AND KIDS AND. IT'S OF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT CAN BE PUT IN
PLACE THERE FOR THOSE FOR FOR
EXAMPLE LIKE HALF OF THOSE
FAMILIES WHO SO THEY NEVER END
UP GETTING INFECTED OR AND I'M
ON THE STREET BUT THEN THE OTHER
HALF. I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO BE
LOOKING AT PRODUCTION. AND
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
GREAT WELL I I'LL NOTICE I THINK
A NUMBER COLLEAGUES KNOW.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE WE
A NUMBER OF BILLS.
TO TRY TO CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THE EVICTION ANTENNA CRISIS BUT.
THAT THE THAT THE CHALLENGE
FACING.
HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS IS ONE
WERE ALL GRAPPLING WITH A SINNER
DEL THAT IT TO THE FOR THAT A
NUMBER OF US ARE SUPPORTIVE OF A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION. OF THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET SURPLUS GOING TO
HOMELESSNESS
BUT THEN THE QUESTION IS WHAT WE
GONNA SPENT ON
ONE FOR ONE FINAL QUESTION ON A
LEAF.
MISTER BROWN OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION OF I HAVE I THINK
ANECDOTALLY A SENSE OF SOME OF
THE DIFFERENCES AND SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN URBAN. AND RURAL
HOMELESSNESS TO COULD YOU
ADDRESS FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT YOU SEE POTENTIALLY
DIFFERENCES THAT WE NEED TO BE
SENSITIVE TO AS POLICY MAKERS.
AND AND HOW WE OUGHT TO THINK
ABOUT TAYLOR DIFFERENT
SOLUTIONS.
IN MORE RURAL COMMUNITY.
YEAH I MEAN I THINK OUR ROLE
COMMUNITIES A DOES LOOK GOOD
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
.
AND REGARDING THEIR DISSIDENT
FRIEND DEMOGRAPHICS AND STUFF
THAT WE SEE.
YOU KNOW AND.
SO FIRST FIRST SPECIFICALLY FOR
OUR COUNTY. YOU KNOW IT'S HAVING
THE ABILITY TO HAVE.
WIDE REACHING SCOPE OF SERVICES
TO THESE INDIVIDUALS I'M
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY. I'M
RAISING AWARENESS EVEN ABOUT
HOUSING PROGRAMS I'M.
FOR A YOU KNOW HAD THROUGH THE
MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS I'M
HAVING WITH DIFFERENT MEMBERS
FROM OUR COUNTY.
SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW THEY THEY
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND EVEN A
LOT ABOUT HOW THESE PROGRAMS
OPERATE OR HOW THEY EVEN WORK.
YOU KNOW SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WORKING WITH.
WITHIN OUR COUNTY TO CREATE
MULTIPLE ACCESS POINTS
THROUGHOUT THE DIFFERENT CITIES.
WITH DIFFERENT CHURCHES
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO MAY BE.
THIS TO BE ACCESSING YES YOU
DOLLARS HERE WHO MAY BE ON THE
VERGE OF BEING EVICTED CAN
ACCESS SOME OF THOSE DOLLARS.
I'M WHO ARE MAYBE HOMELESS
LIVING IN SOMEONE'S GARAGE JR
SOMEWHERE HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEY AB PLACE THAT THEY
KNOW THEY CAN GO TO TO RECEIVE
EAT YES TWO DOLLARS.
.
NOW THAT THE HOUSING COSTS
PACIFIC LIKE OUR COUNTY IS AND
HAS EXPENSIVE. SO EVEN THOUGH WE
DO HAVE A SH. OBVIOUSLY HOUSING
SHORTAGE.
ESP DOLLARS FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
AT FIRST SPECIFICALLY FOR
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS ACTUALLY CAN
BE UTILIZED TO.
MAYBE FOR RAPIDLY HOUSING
DOLLARS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LESS
VULNERABLE TO GET THEM OFF THE
STREETS.
WHICH THEN IT COMES BACK TO THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS SITUATION
THAT WE SEE.
SO.
WE FEEL THAT YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK
TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT. WITHIN THE NEXT THREE TO
FIVE YEARS.
WE FILL HELPFUL AND THAT THERE
WILL BE MORE HOUSING AVAILABLE.
FOR FAMILIES IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES TO ACCESS SO THAT
THERE ARE YOU KNOW WHETHER
DOUBLING DOUBLING UPPER. BASS
AND IF I HOUSES WERE SLEEPING IN
CARS AND VEHICLE SO THEY WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
HOUSING.
WHERE IT'LL BE AFFORDABLE THE
RAPIDLY HOUSING DOLLARS WILL BE
ABLE TO AND BENEFIT THE MARIA
SHE DOLLARS?
?
SO YOU KNOW SPECIFIC FOR OUR
COUNTY WE DO FEEL LIKE NEXT FIVE
YEARS BECAUSE THE CITY HAS A
PLAN TO BUILD A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
FOR FAMILY IS TIED IN WITH
TWENTY UNITS OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
BUT THE PLANT THAT WILL HAPPEN
FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS SO IT'S
KIND LIKE WHAT WE DO AN INTERIM.
Y. WERE TRYING TO SOFTEN THIS
ISSUE.
SO RURAL ONLY RECRUITING ACCESS
POINTS FOR PEOPLE CAN ACCESS
THE.
YES ST AHLERS
I OF HIS THINK IN LUKE THAT
THOUGH THOUGH.
SARA CAO SKIS BILL THOUGH
ASSESSABLE DWELLING UNITS MAYBE
THAT MIGHT BE.
EXCESS REDRAWING NO IDEA MIGHT
BE.
A FIT FOR RURAL AREAS WHERE
THERE'S MORE.
SPREAD OUT.
.
HOUSING AND YOU KNOW THEY COULD
BUILD A FEW ASSESS RECALLING
UNITS IN THE.
THAT MIGHT HELP.
THAT MIGHT THAT MIGHT BE AN
IDEA.
.
YEAH I'M A LOOK AT THAT FIRST WE
HAVE ONE SHELTER REALLY FOR THE
WHOLE COUNTY INSISTS MONTH LOS
BANOS ACCESSING AND THEY'RE NOT
GONNA DRIVE.
YEAH.
TO BE SHELTERED.
FOR AN HOUR AND HER SPACE
LOOKING TO BUILD DIFFERENT
DEVELOPMENTS
SMALLER DEVELOPMENTS IN MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES WOULD BE
DEATHLY HELPFUL. OKAY WE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
A CERTAIN PERSONALITY OF ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
GREAT OKAY.
WHEN WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR FEEDBACK OBVIOUS AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION.
LET'S MOVE TO OUR FINAL PANEL
TODAY.
ONE OF FIGHT UP.
KEVIN WILSON AND MIRIAM SUCK
AND JUST TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT. ARE WE VAST.
MISTER WILSON TO DISCUSS THE
IMPACT OF.
THE RECENTLY ENACTED FEDERAL TAX
PLAN.
.
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS.
ALLIES IN CONGRESS PASSED OUR
AND THEIR IMPACT ON THE FOUR
WIVES AND TAX CREDITS. AND THEN
WE HAVE ALSO INVITED OUT MS UC
TO PROVIDE SOME THOUGHTS ON.
WHAT THE STATE CAN CONSIDER
WITH REGARDS TO?
LAND USE AND.
RELATED IDEA SO WITH THAT.
FEDERAL TAX REFORM.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME THIS IS A.
A BIG HONOR FOR ME TO BE HERE TO
TALK TO YOU GUYS ABOUT.
HOW SOME OF THE IMPACT THAT THE
RECENTLY ENACTED FEDERAL TAX
BILL?
WILL HAVE ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INDUSTRY.
COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE CLOSER
TO MICROPHONE.
PERFECT GOOD.
SO I THINK ARE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES.
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF.
FEDERAL TAX REFORM ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IS THAT WHILE THE TAX BILL.
RETAINED THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDITS.
AND THE PRIVATE ACTIVITY BONDS.
WERE EXPECTING TO SEE A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION.
IN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION AND PRESERVATION AS A
RESULT OF THE TAX BILL.
I THIS IS PRIMARILY.
A FUNCTION OF THE DECREASE IN
THE. IN THE CORPORATE TAX RATE.
SO THE REDUCTION OF THE
CORPORATE INCOME TAX RATE FROM.
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT TO TWENTY
ONE PERCENT.
WILL REDUCE THE TAX LOSS.
BENEFITS
OF THESE TAX CREDIT INVESTMENTS.
SINCE THE VALUE OF THE
DEPRECIATION EXPENSE DEDUCTIONS.
WILL BE REDUCED.
SO WHILE THE CHANGE IN THE TAX
RATE DOES NOT AFFECT THE VALUE
OF THE TAX CREDITS THEMSELVES.
THE ADDITIONAL BENEFITS THAT ARE
BUILT INTO THE INVESTORS
PRICING.
ARE SIGNIFICANTLY DIMINISHED.
SO WE ARE CONDUCTING A STUDY.
THAT SUGGESTED JUST THE MERE
ANTICIPATION OF TAX REFORM
DURING TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
HOW REDUCED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION BY ELEVEN PERCENT?
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOLLOWING
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION.
THIS ESTIMATED ELEVEN PERCENT
DECREASE.
IS BASED ON A REDUCTION.
PROJECTED REDUCTION OF THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE.
FROM THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT.
WITH TWENTY FIVE PERCENT BEING
THE. WIDELY ADOPTED UNDERWRITING
ASSUMPTION THAT WAS USED DURING
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
IN ANTICIPATION OF TAX REFORM.
SO NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
ENACTED TAX RATE IS TWENTY ONE
PERCENT.
WE'RE ESTIMATING AN ADDITIONAL
DECLINE OF ABOUT THREE PERCENT
SO THAT THE AGGREGATE DECLINE.
OF AFFORDABLE.
HOUSING PRODUCTION PER DOLLAR OF
CREDITS.
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE REDUCTION OF
THE CORPORATE TAX RATE IS
ANTICIPATED TO BE AROUND
FOURTEEN PERCENT.
I'M SO WE WE'VE ESTIMATED.
THE TAX BILL WILL REDUCE THE
FUTURE SUPPLY OF RENTAL HOUSING.
I BY NEARLY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND HOMES
NATIONWIDE OVER TEN YEARS.
.
WHETHER A FEW COMPONENTS OF THE
TAX BILL THAT FACTOR INTO THIS
ESTIMATE.
THE REDUCTION OF THE CORPORATE
TAX RATE IS BY FAR THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THIS
ESTIMATE.
ACCOUNTING FOR ALMOST.
NINETY PERCENT OF THE TOTAL
REDUCTION.
THIS.
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION AND
HOUSING PRODUCTION WOULD ALSO
MEAN. A LOSS OF MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO THOUSAND.
JOBS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
BUSINESS INCOME IN FEDERAL AND
STATE.
TAX REVENUE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
.
WE'VE ALSO ESTIMATED.
THE IMPACT ON EACH STATE.
AND AS AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT.
CALIFORNIA IS.
GOODNESS IS EXPECTED TO SUFFER
THE GREATEST LOSSES.
BY A WIDE MARGIN.
I WE'VE ESTIMATED THAT OUT OF
THAT NEARLY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND HOMES.
THAT WILL BE LOST OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS.
ALMOST FIFTY THOUSAND OF THESE
HOMES WOULD BE CALIFORNIA HOMES.
I THEN THIS IS NEARLY TWICE THE
AMOUNT OF HOMES.
FOR THAT THE NEXT STATE ON THE
LIST.
SO.
I WAS GOING TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE STATE CREDITS IN THE
IMPACT OF THE STATE CREDITS.
FROM AS A RESULT OF TAX REFORM.
SO WITH REGARDS TO STAY CREDITS.
HI IN GENERAL FUND THE NON
CERTIFICATED STATE CREDITS
ARE STRONGLY CORRELATED WITH
THIS FEDERAL TAX RATE.
THERE'S KIND OF AN INVERSE
RELATIONSHIP.
SUCH THAT WHEN THE FEDERAL TAX
RATE WAS THIRTY FIVE PERCENT.
THE STATE CREDIT PRICES.
WE'RE GENERALLY IN THE IN THE
SIXTY FIVE CENT RANGE.
SO NOW THAT THE FEDERAL TAX RATE
HAS BEEN REDUCED TO TWENTY ONE
PERCENT.
WE EXPECT A SEE AN INCREASE IN
THE NON CERTIFICATED CREDIT
PRICING.
OF ROUGHLY TWENTY PERCENT.
NOW CALIFORNIA'S CERTIFICATED
CREDIT PROGRAM. PROVIDES A
NUMBER OF BENEFITS
INCLUDING A MECHANISM THAT
SEVERS THIS CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE CREDIT PRICES. AND FEDERAL
TAX RATES THAT CAN.
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE CREDIT
PRICES FOR THE DEVELOPERS THAT
ELECT THEIR CERTIFICATED
CREDITS.
I WOULD EXPECT THAT THE
CERTIFICATED CREDIT SHOULD STILL
PRICE HIGHER THAN THE NON
CERTIFICATED CREDITS.
BUT AS A RESULT OF TAX REFORM.
THIS.
PRICING DIFFERENTIAL WILL
PROBABLY SHRINK A LITTLE BIT.
.
SO.
S..
AS MANY OF U. KNOW HOW THE
HOUSING CREDIT IS WIDELY
REGARDED. AS ONE OF THE NATION'S
MOST SUCCESSFUL TOOLS FOR
ENCOURAGING PRIVATE INVESTMENT.
IN AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING.
FINANCING OVER THREE MILLION
APARTMENTS NATIONWIDE FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX.
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
OVER TEN PERCENT OF THOSE HOMES
ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
DIMINISHING ITS EFFECTIVENESS
WILL INVARIABLY PUT PRESSURE ON
OTHER PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
SOURCES.
SO IT'S ENCOURAGING TO SEE ALL
THE NEW FUNDING SOURCES COMING
ONLINE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN DC ADVOCATES ARE ACTIVELY
PURSUING MEASURES TO MITIGATE
THESE RECENT LOSSES BY
EXPANDING.
AND IMPROVING THE CREDIT
PROGRAM.
SUCH EFFORTS HAVE BEEN UNDER
WAY SINCE BEFORE THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN ELECTION.
PERHAPS MOST NOTABLY THROUGH THE
WELL KNOWN CAN'T WELL HATCH
BILL.
I AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS SENATOR
WIDENS MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT BILL.
EARLIER THIS MONTH THERE WASN'T
A SERIOUS EFFORT. TO INCLUDE
PROVISIONS OF THE CAN'T WELL
HATCH BELL.
IN THE TWO YEAR FEDERAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT.
SO WHILE THESE
EFFORTS FELL SHORT.
WE STILL LOOK AT THIS IS AN
ENCOURAGING SIGN.
AS WE HAVE NEVER BEEN CLOSER TO
GETTING SOME OF THE CAN'T WELL
HATCH PROVISIONS.
AND ACTED INTO LAW.
THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS TWENTY
THREE CO SPONSORS IN THE SENATE
THIRTEEN DEMOCRATS AND TEN
REPUBLICANS. AS WELL AS A
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR CO SPONSORS
IN THE HOUSE ROUGHLY A QUARTER
OF THE HOUSE.
SPLIT EVENLY WITH A SIXTY TWO
DEMOCRATS AND SIXTY TWO
REPUBLICANS.
ADVOCATES ARE WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT THIS BILL IS WELL
POSITIONED.
TO BE ADDED TO ANY POTENTIAL TAX
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE.
THE CONGRESS COULD CONSIDER THIS
YEAR.
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY WILL MOST
LIKELY BE A SPENDING BILL.
SLATED FOR BEFORE MARCH TWENTY
THIRD.
I THINK.
I OUT I JUST WANNA POINT OUT
THAT I THINK THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ASPECT OF THIS CAN'T
WELL HATCH BILL.
IS THAT. IS THE FIFTY PERCENT
INCREASE AN ANNUAL AUTHORITY FOR
HOUSING CREDITS.
AND INCREASING THE PER CAPITA
ALLOCATION AMOUNT WILL HELP
MITIGATE THE LOSSES
RESULTING FROM TAX REFORM.
HOW WE ESTIMATE THAT THE FIFTY
PERCENT INCREASE
COULD ADD?
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS.
NATIONWIDE OVER TEN YEARS.
I ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION RECENTLY LA
AND RECENTLY RELEASED THEIR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET REQUESTS.
AS ANTICIPATED IT'S NOT GOOD
NEWS FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INDUSTRY OR COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
HOW THE PLAN SEEKS TO CUT HIDE
FUNDING BY ALMOST FIFTEEN
PERCENT?
WITH CUTS TO A VARIETY OF OTHER
PROGRAMS.
AND A PROPOSED ELIMINATION OF CD
BG AND HOME.
FOR A NUMBER OF REASON.
THE THIS BUDGET ISN'T UNLIKELY
TO ADVANCE.
INSTEAD CONGRESS WILL NOW FOCUS
ON COMPLETING THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN APPROPRIATIONS
PROCESS.
WITH THE GOAL OF AN ACTING AN
OMNIBUS BILL.
BEFORE THE CONTINUING RESOLUTION
FUNDING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
EXPIRES.
ON MARCH TWENTY THIRD.
CENTER HELD. YOU KNOW I'M.
I WAS SO FOCUSED ON AND THE SALT
ISSUE AND THE MORTGAGE DEDUCTION
ISSUE ASSOCIATE WITH A TAX PLAN
THAT I CONFESS I'M.
A LITTLE HAZY ABOUT.
THIS AREA OF THE TAX PLAN AND I
WOULD LOVE IT IF YOU JUST GAVE A
LAYMAN'S.
DESCRIPTION OF HOW.
THE.
TAX CREDIT USED TO WORK AND HOW
IT'S BEEN CHANGED BY THE FEDERAL
TAX PLAN.
SO THE TAX CREDIT ITSELF WAS NOT
CHANGED IT WAS LEFT IN THE CODE
THE SAME CODE SECTION NO CHANGES
TO THAT CODE SECTION.
ANOTHER COUNTERPART SO THERE'S
TWO NOTICED TWO CREDITS THERE'S
A NINE PERCENT CREDIT. AND A
FOUR PERCENT CREDIT FOR PERCENT
CREDIT IS ALWAYS PAIRED WITH
PRIVATE ACTIVITY BONDS.
THE PRIVATE ACTIVITY BONDS WERE
WERE VERY CLOSE TO BEING
ELIMINATED THROUGH TAX REFORM
BUT THEY ENDED UP.
STAYING IN.
IN THE TAX CODE AS WELL SO TAX
CREDITS PRIVATE ACTIVITY BONDS
STATE IN THE CODE.
AT THE BIGGEST IMPACT THOUGH IS
THAT.
THE TAX RATES THE FOR THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE GOING FROM
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT TO TWENTY
ONE PERCENT.
IT'S GOING TO REDUCE THE
INVESTORS WERE TURNED ON THEIR
TAX CREDIT INVESTMENTS
AND AS A RESULT THERE WILL BE
LESS EQUITY SO I HAVE HAD A
CHART HERE THAT SHOW THAT THERE
WOULD BE.
THE VALUE.
A HEARD THE PRICES ARE PRESENT
PRICES THAT INVESTORS ARE
WILLING TO PAY FOR THE RIGHTS
HAS ROBBED.
EXACTLY BY. ROUGHLY FIFTEEN
PERCENT
SO EVERY TAX CREDIT
DEFAULT THE IT IS FURTHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDIT
BUT I'M SEEING IT.
DID YOU THE SAME LOGIC APPLIES
TO NEARLY EVERY TAX CREDIT IN
THE CODE.
THAT CORPORATIONS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF.
NO NO I THINK EACH ONE OF US IS
GOING TO HAVE ITS OWN DYNAMICS.
.
SO WHAT'S SPECIAL ABOUT THIS ONE
IN THAT SENSE VERSES ANOTHER TAX
CREDIT.
VERSUS LIKE SAY THAT THE NEW
MARKETS TAX CREDIT OR. OR ANY
OTHER TIME SOME MANY NOT ME NINE
HOUSING REALLY TAX CREDIT.
MOON.
SO I GET LIKE FOR EXAMPLE.
.
THE NEW MARKETS TAX CREDIT.
SERVER SOME ARE INDEED TAX
CREDIT OR SOMETHING ALONG THOSE
LINES
OKAY. SO I MEET EACH ONE OF
THOSE LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THIS IS
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
CREDITS TO CHART THAT I'M
SHOWING HERE.
IT'S SHOWING THAT THE CREDIT
PRICES.
ARE MORE THAN A DOLLAR PER
CREDIT THAT'S A CREDIT THAT'S
BEING.
EARNED BY THAT INVESTOR OVER TEN
YEAR PERIOD RECENT THEY'RE
PAYING MORE THAN THAT DOLLARS
FOR THE CREDIT NOW. IS A
BEGINNING ADDITIONAL BENEFITS AS
A RESULT OF THEIR INVESTMENT.
IN THE PRIMARY.
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT THAT THESE
INVESTORS ARE GETTING.
S. I IS TAX LOSSES FROM THE
DEPRECIATION OF THE BUILDING.
AND THOSE TAX LOSSES.
HAVE A LOWER VALUE AS A RESULT
OF THAT THE CORPORATE TAX RATE
RIGHT NOW OTHER TAX CREDITS.
WILL HAVE DIFFERENT PRICING
MECHANISMS BECAUSE ARE BEING
AWARDED TO THE INVESTORS OVER
DIFFERENT PERIOD OF TIME. IT'S
IT'S VERY HARD TO CORRELATE THE
TWO. SWAT WHERE IS THIS GONNA DO
IT WOULD SO SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE BILL.
WELL THIS IS ACTUALLY SHOWING
SHOWS A STEEP DROP RIGHT AFTER
THE ELECTION.
IN ANTICIPATION OF TAX REFORM
RIGHT.
SO THAT ROB IS.
GEN JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
YEAH YEAH THERE WAS A SHARP DROP
BECAUSE RIGHT AFTER THE ELECTION
EVERYONE STARTED TO REALIZE THAT
THERE IS A STRONG LIKELIHOOD
THAT TAX REFORM WOULD BE ENACTED
INTO WHERE IS IT. WHERE THE
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY EIGHTEEN
MEMBERS ARE WE NOT KNOW YET?
NO NO THIS IS KIND OF IT'S KIND
A THREE MONTH ROLLING AVERAGE SO
WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA YET. BUT
IS IT DROP FURTHER.
BICU I I THINK WE'RE KIND OF
SEEM TO
DROP RIGHT THERE IN DECEMBER. I
THINK I THINK YOU KNOW WE WOULD
LIKE US AND THEY WERE USING A
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT RATE FOR
UNDERWRITING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NOW NOW IT'S GONE DOWN TO TWENTY
ONE PERCENT.
SO I THINK WE'RE SEEING THAT
DROPPED SORT OF AT THE END OF
THAT CHART THERE.
AND SO THIS IS SO THIS IS MONEY
THAT USED TO.
BE AN IMPORTANT DRIVER OF.
OF LOW INCOME HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION.
CORRECT OKAY FOR CREATING THE
SUPPLY RIGHT.
OKAY THIS ISN'T FURTHER
EXACERBATING.
FACTOR THAT'S GOING TO MAKE
CORRECT AN ALREADY BAD SITUATION
FOR HOURS.
AND THERE IS ALSO SO IT'S HARDLY
WE ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE UNITS.
FEWER OVER TEN YEARS AS A RESULT
OF THE TAX BILL
OKAY AND TO MY CLASSICAL HATCH.
SO THERE IS THAT THERE'S A
SENATE BILL CAN'T CAN'T WILL
HAVE TO THE SENATE BILL.
IN DC.
THAT.
HAS A LONG LIST OF IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX
CREDIT.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT OF WHICH IS
RIGHT NOW THAT THE CREDITS ARE
ALLOCATED TO EACH STATE PER
CAPITA A CERTAIN DOLLAR AMOUNT
TO DOLLARS AND.
I THIRTY FIVE CENTS PER PERSON
IN THE STATE. PRISON PROPOSED
ONE ONE OF THE SEVERAL
IMPROVEMENTS. THAT'S INCLUDED IN
THIS BILL IS INCREASING THAT
AMOUNT BY FIFTY PERCENT.
AND SO JUST THAT FIFTY PERCENT
INCREASE ALONE. COULD.
COULD COUNTERACT THE REDUCTION
THEY KNOW THAT TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE UNIT
NATIONWIDE REDUCTION OVER TEN
YEARS. JUST A FIFTY PERCENT
INCREASE ALONE COULD BRING BACK
ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNITS OVER TEN YEARS NATIONWIDE
ANOTHER ASPECT OF THE THAT BILL.
IS THAT YOU KNOW. THAT THE THAT
FOUR PERCENT CREDIT CENTER
PAIRED WITH THE TAX EXEMPT
BONDS.
WITH THE PRIVATE ACTIVITY BONDS.
THERE THIS BILL WOULD RIGHT NOW
THAT THAT CREDIT RATE SORT OF
FLOATS SUGGESTS EVERY MONTH IT'S
BEEN IN THE LOS THREES FOR YOU
KNOW FOR A LONG TIME NOW. AYE
THIS BILL WOULD FIX THAT RATE OF
FOUR PERCENT.
JUST MOVING THAT CREDIT RATE
THAT YOU MULTIPLY THAT YOU'RE
BUILDING BASIS BY TO CALCULATE
THE AMOUNT OF CREDITS THE
BUILDING EARNS. FOR CALCULATING
WITH THAT COULD ADD.
ANOTHER OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNITS OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS AS
WELL.
SO THIS BILL WAS THE STATUS THE
BILL NOW.
.
SO. IT WAS IT WAS CLOSE THERE
WAS A SERIES THERE'S A STRONG
PUSH.
THE THE TWO YEAR FEDERAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT THAT WAS ENACTED.
A TWO WEEKS AGO. THERE'S A VERY
STRONG PUSH TO INCLUDE SOME OF
THESE PROVISIONS IN THAT BILL.
SO CAME CLOSE.%
BUT.
BUT THOSE EFFORTS DID NOT
SUCCEED.
.
BUT IN A SOME PEOPLE IN DC ARE
WORKING VERY HARD.
I TRIED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL IS WELL POSITIONED.
TO.
YOU KNOW.
B. ADDED TO ANY TAX LEGISLATIVE
VEHICLE THAT CONGRESS CONSIDERS
THIS YEAR SO FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
ANOTHER.
.
THAT'S ANOTHER SPENDING
RESOLUTION THAT'S DO YOU KNOW
WITHIN THE NEXT HOUR MONTH. SO
THERE THERE'S A CHANCE THAT THAT
MIGHT BE.
INCLUDED AS WELL FOR EXAMPLE I
KNOW THAT.
THAT THE REPUBLICANS ARE EAGER
TO FIX
A CERTAIN GLITCH IN THE TAX
CODE.
.
AND SO THAT THAT MIGHT YOU KNOW
OPEN THEM UP IN SOME OF THE
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVEN'T YET
SUPPORTED THE BILL ALTHOUGH I AS
I MENTIONED THERE ARE NUMEROUS
SPONSORS FUND BOTH SIDES. FOR
THIS BILL HOT THAT I COULD OPEN
IT UPSWINGS YOU KNEW WHAT WHY
THEY DIDN'T INCLUDE.
THE LANGUAGE IN THE LAST GO
AROUND.
I Y. GOT PULLED OUT YOU CITY
JUST AS YOU SAID IT FELL SHORT
OF THE BUDGET OF OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET YOU SAID IT FELL
SHORT A COUPLE WEEKS AGO YEAH NO
I DO NOT. KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW
THAT GOT NEGOTIATED OUT.
SO.
ANDERSON THANK YOU.
IF I COULD OF LEND A LITTLE BIT
OF A LAY PERSON'S.
.
UNDERSTANDING OF OF OF THE TAX
SITUATION SO A SO LAST YEAR I AM
PROUD THAT OUR LEGISLATURE DID
YEOMAN'S WORK TO PASS TO
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE MEASURES. AS
YOU KNOW S. B. TWO IS GOING TO
BE ABOUT A QUARTER BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. ARE S. B. THREE
WITH OUR CENTER BELL.
WILL ADD TO THAT TO THE TUNE OF
COMBINED BETWEEN SP TWO SP THREE
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT COMPARES TO THE ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT WE USE TO INVEST IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FOR THE GREAT RECESSION SO WERE
TRYING TO GET OUR WAY HALFWAY
UP.
BECAUSE OF THE TRUMP TAX CUTS
WE ARE LOSING AS A STATE HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FINANCING SO
ANOTHER WORDS IF CENTER REBELS
BOND IS NOT PASSES NOVEMBER
THROUGH THIS TAX CUT. IS CENTER
BILLS A MEASURE DOES NOT PASS
THIS NOVEMBER HEAVEN FORBID IF
IT DOESN'T PASS. THE THE AND
WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY HAPPEN IS WE
TOOK ONE STEP FORWARD AND DONALD
TRUMP AS ALLIES TOOK US TWO
STEPS BACK.
IF WE DO PASS THE MEASURE IN
NOVEMBER WE TAKE TWO STEPS
FORWARD AND DONALD TRUMP'S TAX
CUTS TAKE US ONE STEP BACK
SO WE HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY
HURT BY WHAT HAPPENED. WITH.
THE TAX CUTS WHEN IT IS IN THE
FORM IN THE FOR HOUSING ARENA.
AND THAT'S A VERY REAL IMPACT
ON ANYONE IS TRY TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS I CANNOT I WANT I WANT
TO GO TO THE NEXT PRESENTATION.
YEAH YOU I KNOW YOU AS OUR DEEP
DEEP DEEP IN THE WEEDS OF.
HOUSING FINANCE I JUST
APPRECIATE THAT DECLARED SURE.
IF WE GO TO THE NEXT
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
GREAT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
MY NAME IS MARION SUCK I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
COMMUNICATION AND URBAN
DISPLACEMENT PROJECT.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
INVITING ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE NEED TO ADDRESS
DISPLACEMENT TODAY. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO AREN'T
FAMILIAR WITH OUR OUR CENTER WE
AYE CONDUCT IN RESEARCH ON
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO ADVANCE
EQUITABLE AND RESILIENT FUTURES
WITH COMMUNITIES.
OUR WORK IS IT IS ARRANGED
AROUND THE THREE MAIN PROJECTS
AT THE BOTTOM AND THE ONE I'LL
BE SPEAKING TO YOU MOST TODAY IS
OUR URBAN DISPLACEMENT PROJECT.
I WHICH SEEKS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE DRIVERS OF
DISPLACEMENT AND WORK WITH
COMMUNITIES TO DESIGN EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO ON THE DATA
THAT YOU ALL KNOW VERY VERY WELL
BUT JUST REGARDING REGARDLESS TO
SAY THAT.
AT THE BUT THE.
BOTTOM ROW HERE SHOWS YOU THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL INCOME YOU NEED
TO MAKE TO AFFORD RENT FOR YOUR
AVERAGE TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU'RE A TWO WORKER HOUSEHOLD
MAKING MINIMUM WAGE EACH OF YOU
NEED TO BE WORKING ELEVEN HOURS
A DAY.
TWO.
TO AFFORD RENT AND THAT TIME
AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILY.
BUT THIS IS SOME DATA FROM FROM.
H. CD THAT SHOWS THAT WHILE ALL
OF US OR FEELING THE CRUNCH OF
THIS.
TERRIBLE HOUSING CRISIS
UP IT'S REALLY OUR OUR LOW
INCOME AN EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
AS WE WERE HEARD ABOUT TODAY.
THAT ARE MOST SEVERELY BURDEN SO
HERE ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE YOU
CAN SEE IN BLUE SEVERELY RENT
BURDENS THAT'S ME THAT'S
SPENDING MORE THAN FIFTY PERCENT
OF YOUR INCOME ON RENT. A INNING
GREEN IS A RENT BURDEN THIS IS
THIRTY PERCENT OF YOUR INCOME ON
RENT AND AS YOU CAN SEE. THE
HIGHER YOUR INCOME THE LESS BIRD
AND YOU ARE TO.
THEN WHAT WE KNOW ALSO IS THAT
IF YOU TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
ARE HOUSING COSTS ARE STATE
POVERTY LEVELS RATES JUMPED FROM
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY ONE PERCENT.
UP WHICH IS CLEARLY CONTRIBUTING
TO THE FACT THAT NEARLY A
QUARTER OF OUR STATE'S CHILDREN
ARE GROWING UP IN POP.
ALL OF THIS WHICH WE ALL KNOW
VERY WELL AS PART PERSONALLY I
CREATED BY THE UNDERSUPPLY. OF
OF HOUSING.
BUT ALL OF THIS IS CONTRIBUTING
TO MASK DISPLACEMENT I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'VE SEEN THE DATA
THAT CAME OUT TODAY FROM THE LA
O'BRIEN YOU LAWYERS ANALYSIS OF
IRS DATA.
BUT HE SHOWED IN THIS DATA SET.
THAT WE ARE SEEING A MASS OUT
MIGRATION OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME RESIDENTS FROM CALIFORNIA
ACROSS THE STATE. A AND THE ONLY
PEOPLE THAT CAN AFFORD TO MOVE
HERE ARE VERY HIGH INCOME AND
VERY HIGH
KITTY PEOPLE.
HERE'S SOME DATA FOR THE BAY
AREA WHICH I KNOW VERY WELL.
WITH WHICH WE CAN SEE HERE IS
THAT BECAUSE OF.
SOME HERE THAT CAME OUT FROM
READ FAN IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN.
THAT ONE IN FOUR PEOPLE LOOKING
FOR HOMES IN CALIFORNIA LOOKED
OUTSIDE OF THE STATE.
A BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE BAY AREA
LOST TWENTY TWO THOUSAND AFRICAN
AMERICAN RESIDENTS. AND THREE
QUARTERS OF THOSE WHO HAVE
LAUGHED SINCE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
MAKE LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND SO
IT'S IMPACTING US ALL BUT WE
KNOW IT'S IMPACTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE THE MOST.
THE CASE IS A GOOD QUESTION SITE
THEN THE LAST SLIDE YEAH WHAT.
I MEAN WHAT WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE CALIFORNIA POPULATION MAKES
LESS THAN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
I DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER FOR YOU
RIGHT NOW OKAY.
OKAY GUYS IF. I'M GONNA GET A
SENSE OF THAT'S.
CORRELATED WITH THE GENERAL
POPULATION OR IF IT'S
PARTICULARLY BURDENED.
WAIT IF DEMOCRATIC EVALUATE THAT
THAT THE ASSERTION YOU'RE MAKING
AND. IN THAT SENSE IT'S I I
THOUGHT THAT THE MEANING OF
SENATE THIRTY EIGHT OUT WITH
FORTY THOUSAND.
NOW THAT I DON'T HAVE IT OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD.
IT MIGHT BE REPRESENTATIVE BUT
AGAIN THIS IS JUST KIND OF
REFLECTIVE OF WHO'S MOVING OUT
IN HIS MOVING IN.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT GEOGRAPHY
WHICH WE THINK ABOUT A LOT.
AND AT THIS IS A MAP.
A COPY OF THE MAP THAT OF OUR
DISPLACEMENT RISK MAP WHICH
WE'VE JUST RECENTLY REALLY
EXPANDED OUT TO SACRAMENTO AND
DOWN TO SAN ACT SANTA CRUZ.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE THIS
ARE DISTRIBUTION OF WHERE THIS
IS OCCURRING WHERE THE RISK OF
DISPLACEMENT IS CURRYING. WE SEE
THAT OVER SIXTY PERCENT OF LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS THE BAY
AREA ARE LIVING IN NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE AT RISK OF OUR ALREADY
UNDERGOING DISPLACEMENT.
THAT'S ROUGHLY UP TEN PERCENT IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS SINCE OUR
PREVIOUS ANALYSIS SO WE KNOW
THAT THIS CRISIS IS
ACCELERATING.
AND AS WE HEARD EARLIER AND WE
KNOW PRETTY WELL AT THIS POINT
THE THE. DISPLACEMENT CRISIS HAS
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
CHILDREN WORKERS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
A THIS IS A RESEARCH BRIEF WE
CAME OUT WITH LAST YEAR FROM A
SURVEY WE DID OF ACTED
HOUSEHOLDS INS FROM SAN MATEO
COUNTY. WE'RE NOT RIGHT NOW IN
THE PROCESS OF REPLICATING THE
SURVEY FOR SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
ON IN WHAT WE FOUND A IN THIS
SURVEY IS THAT DISPLACEMENT IS
INTIMATELY CONNECTED WITH OUR
HOUSING UP OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS.
WHEN IN THREE DISPLACE
HOUSEHOLDS REPORTED SOME PERIOD
OF HOMELESSNESS OR MARTIAL
HOUSING IN THE TWO YEARS
FOLLOWING THEIR AFFECTIONS ARE
DISPLACEMENT.
THIRTY THREE PERCENT OF THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WERE DIS PLACE
LEFT THE COUNTY UP ALTHOUGH SO
THAT SAYING THAT THE MAJORITY
STAY IN THE COUNTY BECAUSE THEY
OFTEN ARE DOUBLING UP THERE ARE
LIVING IN SOME SORT OF MARGINAL
HOUSING WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS
OR. ON COUCHES.
BUT THOSE THAT LEFT UP LEFT THE
COUNTY ALTOGETHER ON IN THOSE
THAT WERE DISPLACED OUT OF THE
COUNTY AND. IN THE PAST MAJORITY
OF THEM ARE JUST PLACE TO WORSE
OFF NEIGHBORHOODS AND THIS IS
VALIDATING SOME RESEARCH THAT
CAME OUT OF PHILADELPHIA LAST
YEAR I BELIEVE. THAT SHOWED THAT
DISPLAYS HOUSEHOLDS MOVED TO
LOWER LOWER OPPORTUNITY AREAS.
SO AS YOU ALL KNOW THERE'S NO
QUESTION WHERE THE SEVERE
HOUSING COURT SHORTAGE AND NEW
SUPPLIES CRITIC CRITICAL DUE TO
ALL OF YOUR HARD WORK AYE WE'VE
MADE AMAZING PROGRESS AT AND VIA
YOU KNOW. ACCELERATING THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING.
BUT THE QUESTION REALLY IS WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT AND AND SLOW THE
TIED RIGHT NOW TODAY.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE DID WE PUT
OUT THIS RESEARCH BRIEF THAT
LOOKED AT MERCURY HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
AND TRY TO UNDERSTAND ITS
IMPACTS ON HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
AS WELL AS A DISPLACEMENT RATES
AND WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT.
ALTHOUGH THE PRODUCTION OF
MERCURY HOUSING IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES LEAD TO LOWER MEDIAN
RENTS IN FOR THE FIFTH FIFTEEN
YEARS LATER.
THE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY LEVELS
THE HOUSING BURDEN FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS INCREASED IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS SO WHAT
BASICALLY WHAT THIS IS SAYING IS
THAT. YOU WHEN WE PRODUCE A FULL
MARKET RATE HOUSING IT IS NOT
INCREASING THE AFFORDABILITY
LEVELS OF LOW INCOME WRATH
TENANTS.
SO I THINK YOU KNOW BASICALLY
DRIVING HOME THIS THIS QUESTION
WHAT WE HEARD EARLIER BUILDING
MARKET RATE HOUSING IS NOT GONNA
SOLVE THE HOW THE HOUSING CRISIS
IN THE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS FOR
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS WE NEED IT
NO QUESTION WE NEED IT. BUT IS
NOT THE SOLUTION FOR THE THAT
LOW END OF THE SCALE.
WHAT WE ALSO FOUND IS THAT
WHILE AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL
PRODUCING HOUSING ALTOGETHER FOR
BOTH SUBSIDIZE IN MARKET RATE A
REDUCE DISPLACEMENT PRESSURES?
EIGHT BIT THE PRODUCTION OF
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
HAD TWICE THE IMPACT OF MARKET
RATE HOUSING.
SO BY ALL MEANS AND WE ALL KNOW
AND YOU'LL KNOW VERY WELL WE
NEED TO BE PRODUCING MORE MARKET
RATE HOUSING BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST OUR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
THAT LIVE IN THE STATE OR THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
BUT IF WE DO SO WE NEED TO ANY
FOR FOCUSED ON THAT WE NEED TO
BE MAKING SURE THAT WERE LINKING
PRODUCTION TO PRETTY
ACTIONS WHERE WHERE THE MARKET
WANTS TO PRODUCE NEW HOUSING. IS
WHERE RENTS ARE GROWING WHERE
THEY CAN MAKE PROFIT AND SO WE
NEED TO BE PROTECTING TENANTS IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS WE CAN'T
DEVELOP MORE AND THAT'S GOING TO
HELP THE PEOPLE LIVING THERE NOW
BECAUSE THE LOW INCOME PEOPLE
LIVING THERE NOW ARE NOT GONNA
BE HELPED BY THAT MARKET RATE
HOUSING SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE HELPING THEM WHILE
ALSO PRODUCING MARKET RATE
HOUSING.
WE NEED TO BE REQUIRED
AFFORDABILITY BUT OBVIOUSLY
WITHOUT HINDERING DEVELOPMENT
AND THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT WORK
I ALSO TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE CASA. GROUP
WORKING GROUP IN THE BAY AREA
THEY'VE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
GREAT WORK ON THIS AND HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU RATE SIZE
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS OR
NOT KILLING TWO ALLOTMENT.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT AYE
YOU NOTE. REMOVING AFFORDABLE
UNITS FROM FROM A.
FROM OUR MARKET.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
PRODUCING MARKET RATE UNITS.
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT
WORK COMING OUT OF LOS ANGELES
ON NO NET LOSS POLICIES AND
LANGUAGE.
A AND THEN FINALLY I HOPE YOU
ARE FOR ON THIS TOPIC.
.
IF WE WANT TO BE CREATING
INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
WE REALLY NEED TO BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO LOCAL CONTEXTS IN
HIS PAST HISTORY TO BE ABLE TO A
HOT CREATE FAIR HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SO GETTING BACK TO.
WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSING ON IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WHICH IS REALLY TENURE
PROTECTIONS?
WHAT WE KNOW IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THAT TENER
PROTECTIONS ARE THE BY FAR THE
EXCEPTION NOT THE RULE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES?
ONLY.
ONLY TWELVE CALIFORNIA CITIES
HAVE SOME FOR IMMIGRANTS TO LOOK
STABILIZATION IN ONLY SEVENTEEN
COMMUNITIES HAVE.
JUST CAUSE FOR ADDICTS
PREDICTIONS PROTECTIONS THAT
MEANS EVERYWHERE ELSE WHICH IS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS RIGHT SO YOUR
LANDLORD CAN RAISE THE RENT
HOWEVER MUCH HE WANTS OR HE OR
SHE WANTS. A AT ANY WELL AFTER
YOUR LEASE IS UP AT ANYTIME.
IN THOSE PLACES THAT DON'T HAVE
RENT STABILIZATION OR THEY
CONVICT YOU FOR NO REASON AT ALL
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GIVE A REASON
IF THEY WANT YOU OUT OF THERE
UNITS.
TO.
SO I JUST WANNA END HERE WITH
THESE PRE FIVE BIG BUS BUCKETS
OF THE NET NECESSARY ACTIONS
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT AND I DON'T
REALLY HAVE TIME TO GO INTO
DETAIL ON EACH OF THESE BUT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
ON THE FIRST ONE REALLY IS ABOUT
SHIELDING TENANTS FROM RENT HIKE
SO IN THEIR UNITS ALLOWING THEM
TO STAY IN NOT BEING SURPRISED
BY. YOU KNOW THE TWENTY THIRTY
FIFTY DOUBLING RENTS THAT WE ARE
SEEING IN SOME OF OUR HOT MARKET
CITIES.
UP THAT WE'RE PROTECTING TENANTS
FROM UNFAIR EVICTIONS RIGHT
MAKING SURE THAT THE WHOLE NAM
OR HAS SOME SORT OF ACTUAL JUST
BECAUSE FOR EVICTING.
STRENGTHENING ANTI RETALIATION
LAWS RIGHT NOW I MEAN. IT'S
REALLY NOT THEY'RE NOT EFFECTIVE
RATE AYE IF YOU COMPLAIN ABOUT
YOUR LANDLORD.
NOT FIXING YOUR SINK.
WELL WE SAY BY LAW THAT THEY
CAN'T RETALIATE EVICT YOU THEY
REALLY CAN IT'S VERY HARD TO
PROVE.
AND AND CLEARLY IN SOME THE
WORK I KNOW YOU ALL ARE WORKING
ON IS IS CREATING REALLY
REASONABLE PROCEDURES SO THAT WE
HAVE MORE A FAIR SYSTEM.
LET'S IMPROVE SUBSTANDARD
HOUSING SO WE DON'T SEE GHOST
SHIP FIRES HAPPENING.
IN THAT WHEN PEOPLE DO COMPLAIN
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
EVICTED FROM THEIR HOMES OR
THEIR NOT BEING FORCED OUT
BECAUSE THEIR LANDLORD ISN'T
KEEPING THEIR UNITS UP.
.
THEY CAN SURE ACCESS TO
REPRESENTATION SO RIGHT TO
COUNSEL WE KNOW THAT WHEN WHEN
TENANTS DON'T HAVE
REPRESENTATION THEY DON'T WIN.
A IN COURT.
AND THEN FINALLY ABOUT
PRESERVING HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
SO THIS IS I KNOW THAT A LOT OF
WORKS OR EVEN DONE ON
PRESERVING.
.
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE
UNITS BUT REALLY THINKING ABOUT
THOSE UNITS THAT ARE NOT DE
RESTRICTED THAT ARE WHAT PEOPLE
LIKE TO CALL NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
REALLY DOING MORE TO THINK ABOUT
WHERE THOSE ARE HAD WE STABILIZE
THEM AND WE TAKE THEM OFF THE
MARKET HOW DO WE DO A BETTER JOB
UNDERSTANDING WHEN THEY'RE PART
ABOUT TO GO ON SALE.
SO I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JUST GOV THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
.
WHAT SOLUTIONS WHICH YOU HAVE
TO THE?
SHOOTING.
TENANTS FROM RENT HIKES
AND SOME OF THOSE.
IDEAS YOU HAD TO PROTECT.
TENANTS OUT WE DO.
SO YOU MEAN BEYOND RENT
STABILIZATION. YEAH AND THEN.
ACCESS TO REPRESENTATION.
SO I MEAN RIGHT NOW IT'S THE
CITY OF NEW YORK PASSED A.
TENET RIGHT TO COUNSEL LAW.
I BELIEVE TWO YEARS AGO NOW.
THIS ROLLING OUT RIGHT NOW.
LAST YEAR A CASE THAT'S BEING
ROLLED OUT RIGHT NOW.
.
SO THAT IS PROVIDING
REPRESENTATION TOO I THINK IS
BELOW TWO HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL.
SO SO NOT JUST THE LOWEST
INCOME.
RIGHT NOW IT'S IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET REPRESENTATION
I MEAN THERE'S SOME IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE VERY LOW INCOME MADE YOU
CAN GET REPRESENTATION BUT IT'S
VERY HARD TO FIND A LAWYER.
.
SO THIS IS CREATING A FUN AND
SAN FRANCISCO'S CONSIDERING THIS
NOW I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'VE
ALREADY.
YEAH I KNOW THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
HOUSING WAS WORKING ON SOME
BUDGETS FOR THAT.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
HAPPENING ON IT.
WE KNOW THAT IT'S EFFECTIVE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
SOME WORK THAT HAPPEN THAT DOC
MERELY BECAUSE SERVICES OF EAST
PALO ALTO PUT OUT.
I THINK THEY SAID FOR PLACES
THAT DON'T HAVE TENURE
PROTECTIONS RIGHT TO COUNSEL IS.
HELPING ABOUT.
IN GREEK DECREASING EVICTIONS OR
INCREASING THE LENGTH THAT YOU
CAN STAY IN YOUR APARTMENT BY
ABOUT FIFTEEN PERCENT FOR PLACES
THAT DO HAVE PROTECTIONS. IT'S%
EFFECTIVE AT ROUTE EIGHTY
PERCENT SO.
IT'S REALLY HELPFUL AND
NECESSARY. COME.
STATE FUNDS A LOT OF THE LEGAL
AID PROGRAMS
IS THAT IS THAT WHERE THEY WOULD
GET REPRESENTATION.
RIGHT NOW YES BUT IT'S HARD TO
QUALIFY AND IF YOU ARE
UNDOCUMENTED YOU'D THERE'S NO
RESOURCES AT ALL.
OR VERY FEW.
YEAH SO WE HAVE TO LOOK INTO
THAT I'M ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THAT DEALS WITH THE JUDICIARY'S.
WITHOUT THAT WE LASH WE
INCREASE
FUNDING.
I ASKED HER WHAT KOWSKI
ACTUALLY.
CHAPIN DOT BECAUSE SO.
.
THAT'S HOW WE CAN LOOK AT IT.
GREAT.
SENATE ALLEN.
I'M I JUST WANT TO ASK ABOUT IT
AND THIS WHOLE CONVERSATION
ABOUT.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY YOU KNOW
WHEN WHEN AND.
SO MEMBERS PROP FOR THE.
COSTA HAWKINS REPEAL BILL.
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
I REMEMBER THAT ONE OF THE BIG
ARGUMENTS.
THAT WAS MADE WAS THAT RENT
STABILIZATION RENT CONTROL TETRA
ACTUALLY HAS A DELETERIOUS
EFFECT.
ON.
.
YOU KNOW HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
BECAUSE IT.
YOU SENSE THAT MARKET SIGNALS
ACROSS THE BOARD IN THAT I'M OUT
OF THE ARGUMENT WAS MADE.
AGAINST
THE BILL.
YEAH CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
TO THAT ARGUMENT AND AND SOME OF
THE RESEARCH YOU'VE DONE AND.
YOU'RE MAKING A VERY DIFFERENT
ARGUMENT HERE TODAY.
SO NOT NOT NECESSARILY ABOUT
RENT STABILIZATION.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING FROM THAT
RESEARCH.
.
IS IT I MEAN.
SO THE ONLY RESEARCH I'VE SEEN
ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION WAS
FROM SAINT THIS RECENT SAN
FRANCISCO STUD STUDY OF SAN
FRANCISCO FROM STANFORD.
RESEARCHER.
AND THAT WAS LOOKING AT THE
EXPANSION OF RENT CONTROL IN THE
CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THE ARGUMENT MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM MY READ OF
THE REPORT WAS THAT IT
INCREASED.
RENTS IN THE CITY BECAUSE
LANDLORDS WERE REMOVING UNITS
FROM THE RENT CONTROL MARKET SO
THEY WERE INCREASING CONVERSIONS
TO. TEN SEASON COMMENT AND CONDO
CONVERSIONS
SO IN THAT CASE I WOULD SAY THE
ARGUMENT THERE IS. GREAT CONTROL
BECAUSE LANDLORDS DON'T DON'T
WANT TO DEAL WITH IT.
ART YOU KNOW FOR.
PROBABLY SOME OBVIOUS REASONS.
THEY WERE REMOVING THEIR UNITS
FROM THE RENT CONTROL MARKET I
BELIEVE THIS MIGHT BE.
PRIOR TO SOME OF THE CONDO
CONVERSION LAWS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO BUT.
PROBABLY NOT IT MAY BE MORE OF
AN ENFORCEMENT QUESTION.
SO YOU'RE REDUCING THE SUPPLY
AND THEREFORE THE RENTS ARE
GOING UP.
SO THE ARGUMENT WOULD BE WELL
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
IMPACT OF RENT CONTROL PER SE ON
THE MARKET RATE UNITS BUT RATHER
THAT PEOPLE ARE REMOVING UNITS
FROM THE MARKET AND THEREFORE.
WE NEED TO BE DOING A BETTER JOB
ENFORCING OUR.
CONDO CONVERSION OR. YOUR NOSE
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO THE
ARGUMENT THAT WAS MADE WAS THAT.
IT IN THE MOVIE YOU CAN SPEAK
TO THIS TOO GIVEN YOUR WORK IN.
THIS AREA. ON THE DEVELOPMENT
SIDE. THAT THAT AND IT IMPACTS
THE WILLINGNESS OF DEVELOPERS TO
WANT TO ENTER INTO.
YOU KNOW HOUSING.
NO. IT HOUSING MARKET BECAUSE
THEY LOOK AT IT IS.
HURTING THEIR BOTTOM LINE IN THE
LONG TERM.
SO I THINK PART OF THAT AND I
GUESS THIS IS PART OF THE HEART
COSTA HAWKINS IN EX THE
EXEMPTION OF NEW CONSTRUCTION.
BUT.
I MEAN THE RESEARCH THAT'S OUT
THERE THERE IS LOOKED AT THE
IMPACTS OF RENT STABILIZATION ON
NEW HOUSING PRODUCTION HAS NOT
FOUND THAT IT HAD A NEGATIVE
IMPACT THERE'S BEEN RESEARCH IN
NEW YORK.
THERE'S BEEN RESEARCH IN THE
STATE OF NEW JERSEY THAT HAS
LIKE OVER A HUNDRED
JURISDICTIONS WITH RENT CONTROL.
AND THEY HAVE NOT FOUND THAT IS
HAD NEGATIVE IMPACT ON NEW A NEW
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION SO.
I DON'T KNOW AS FAR AS. I MEAN I
COULD UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT RESEARCH
VALIDATES THAT ARGUMENT.
GREAT THANK YOU SUMMONER. BOTH
SO THAT THE TAX CREDIT UNITS
HAVE FIVE RATE RESTRICTIONS THAT
ARE TIED TO THE AREA MEDIAN
INCOME
SURE AND SO THE.
.
IT IS THE STATE THE TEAK TEAK
ACT WHEN THEY ALLOCATE THE
CREDITS THEY WERE POINTS FOR THE
DEVELOPERS THAT HOLD THE.
.
IS THAT THE RESERVE UNITS FOR
YOU KNOW LOWER AREA MEDIAN
INCOME.
PRINTED I GUESS IF YOU BELIEVE
YOUR TO TAKE OFF YOUR.
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
THAT.
SPECIFIC TO WHAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER IS CONTACT
PROBABLY ABOUT THE IMPACT OF.
MANDATORY SIMPLEST STABILIZATION
POLICIES ON AFFORDABILITY
GENERAL DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT GIVEN WHAT YOU SEEM.
BECAUSE THERE THERE'S OTHER JUST
TWO VERY COMPETING NARRATIVES
HERE IN THIS LEGISLATURE AT WILL
AND.
THOSE LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW IT'S
A TOUGH POLICY QUESTION OF HER.
GERMANY.
IT'S IT'S A DIRTY ONE CHAIR IT'S
OKAY IF YOU DON'T I DON'T THINK
I HAVE A YOU KNOW.
GOOD SOLUTION FOR.
CENTER OF I JUST HAD ONE LAST
QUESTION OF.
WE PASSED S. B. ONE LAST YEAR'S
GOING TO INCREASE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING FIVE BILLION.
DOLLARS A YEAR PART OF IT SO.
SEVEN OR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR TRANSIT.
PROJECTS.
TRANSIT.
AGENCIES.
THEN THERE'S A CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM FOR TRANSIT.
.
THERE'S GONNA BE OTHER TRANSIT
INVESTMENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PASSED SEIZE.
TRANSIT TO.
.
THE I KNOW SURE MA'AFU OF THE.
HERE IS.
DOES DOES.
INVESTMENT TRANSIT.
HAVE YOU SEEN IN THOSE AREAS
WERE TRANSIT HAS BEEN.
.
INVESTMENTS HAVE TAKEN PLACE
LIKE TRANSIT STATIONS.
AND THEY INCREASED.
ACOSTA HOUSING.
IT IS IN THOSE AREAS HAVE THAT
HAS AT LAST TO.
DISPLACEMENT.
ECONOMICALLY.
WHEN.
WE PUT THESE TRANSIT PROJECTS
AND WE DON'T.
WE WE WE YOU KNOW THAT BECOMES
AN ATTRACTIVE AREA WHEN YOU HAVE
A TRANSIT STATION THERE.
YEAH LIKE.
.
LIGHT RAIL BARDS MUNY WHATEVER.
SO IN SHORT YES SO LAST YEAR
WHEN IT IS THAT DOES THAT
AFFECT.
SO LAST YEAR WE PUT OUT OUR
REPORT FROM OUR AIR BE FUNDED
RESEARCH ON THAT PRECISE
QUESTION AND WE DID FIND THAT.
TRANSIT AREAS WHAT WE SAW THAT
IT WAS A MAJOR FACTOR IN
INFLUENCING.
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
SERVE AT THE AGGREGATE LEVEL ON
THEIR SUMMER RESEARCH THAT CAME
OUT FROM U. S. C. THIS PAST YEAR
LOOKING AT THE MORE INDIVIDUAL
HOUSEHOLD LEVEL THERE'S A TON OF
RESEARCH OUT THERE THAT SHOWS
THAT TRANSIT NEW TRANSIT.
INVESTMENT HAS AND.
IS AN AMENITY THAT PEOPLE WANT
INCREASE HOUSING PRICES.
SO HOW WOULD STRATEGIES ARE
THERE FOR.
PROTECT DO. I THINK YOU KNOW ONE
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT TO
LEARN WHAT'S HAPPENING DOWN IN
LOS ANGELES AND THINKING ABOUT
THEIR NO NET LOSS POLICY COLLINS
HAS.
TRANSIT.
YES A HOUSE THERE CAN AFFECT
THE.
A NEIGHBORHOODS AROUND THERE.
MOST A IF IT FITS ONE REASONS
WHY.
.
SOME OF THE.
SOME OF THE KIND OF COMMUNITY
THIS GROUPS ARE SO NERVOUS ABOUT
CENTER WIENER SPELL.
WELL YEAH WILL.
LIVE THE READ THE NEWS THE NEW
BELL ATLANTIC I GUESS OR WHERE
BUT THE LOS ANGELES.
WELL WE WE GOT TIED FOR.
GOT ABOUT THAT AFTER.
I'M IT IS A DISPLACEMENT I
THINK.
.
I THINK THEIR SOMEWHAT OF A
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE HERE.
A CLASS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BY.
NOT PROVIDING REPLACEMENT
HOUSING.
BRIT WAS SO THERE'S SORT OF THIS
REPLACEMENT HOUSING NUMBER
DEBASEMENT HOUSING.
BUILDS UP THE.
ALSO ALL THE
FOR A HOUSING DISAPPEARS. AND.
YOU'VE ONLY GOT IT IN NO THAT
WAS
I HAPPEN
THEN YOU HAVE ALL THE STATE IS
SAY HEY IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF
YOU DO THIS RIGHT THE SERVER
LIKE.
KNOWLEDGE BEFOREHAND YOU KNOW
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND YET
THE NOTHING'S DONE ABOUT.
THAT'S KIND OF.
YEAH SO I MEAN AS I SAID THERE'S
A LOT OF GREAT WORK HAPPENING IN
LA ABOUT THIS AND HOW THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT NO NET LOSS HOW
TO INVENTORY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
RIGHT NOW AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT LOSING IT PEOPLE THAT LOSE
IT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT
THEY.
HAVE THE RIGHT TO RETURN.
HEY WE STABILIZE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY TAKING IT OFF OF
THIS THE SPECULATIVE MARKET IN
THOSE AREAS RIGHT NOW SO I THINK
THERE IS ACTUALLY. QUITE A BIT
THAT CAN BE DONE QUITE A BIT THE
CAN BE ADDED TO THIS BILL MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT YOU ALL
ARE WORKING VERY HARD AT DOING
THAT ARE THAT SENATOR WIENER
STAFF IS.
IN IT SO I THINK THERE'S
TREMENDOUS ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
BECAUSE WE NEED NEW HOUSING NEAR
TRANSIT THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
QUESTION WHAT WE FOUND IN OUR
AIR BE REPORT IS THAT WE'VE
SEVERELY UNDER PRODUCED HOUSING.
GS ACROSS THE BOARD BUT
ESPECIALLY IN TRANSIT AREAS.
SO WE NEED THE NEW HOUSING OR
NEED TO.
A BOTH
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PRODUCTION OF HOUSING
HERE TRANSIT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO. GREAT
THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS A VERY HELPFUL IN
HELPING US.
THINK ABOUT THE FUTURE AND WHAT
ARE TWO RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES
WILL HAVE TO FOCUS ON.
TWENTY.
LET ME JUST TAKE A MOMENT AND
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO'D LIKE
TO SAY THE WORDS AND PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY A TO INDIVIDUALS.
.
PLEASE STEP UP.
SHORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
I JUST WANTED TO TOUCH ON THE
SP TO YOUR ONE FUNDING FOR
HOMELESSNESS.
AND.
WOULD SAY WE ARE GOAL IS TO
MAKE THAT FUNDING AS IMPACTFUL
AS POSSIBLE TO SUSTAINABLE AS
POSSIBLE. TO DO THAT WE REALLY
DO NOT BELIEVE IT SHOULD GO OUT
BY FORMULA TO EVERY
JURISDICTION.
WE THINK IT SHOULD BE FOR
SELECTORS TO ACTIONS TO
DEMONSTRATE NEED AND COMMITMENT.
.
FIRST THE STAND ABILITY WE THINK
THAT THE COMMITMENT OF THOSE
JURISDICTION SHOULD BE THAT THEY
ARE GONNA COMMIT FUTURE SP TWO
DOLLARS. FOR THE SAME PURPOSES.
WE ALSO I THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE SOME LEVEL OF
FLEXIBILITY TO YOUR COMMENT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU AROUND
FLEXIBILITY VERSES TARGETED USE
OF THOSE RESOURCES.
THERE SHOULD BE SOME FLEXIBILITY
BUT STILL TRYING TO MEET THE GAP
AND HOUSING NEEDS.
IN ORDER TO HAVE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT AND THAT IN OUR OPINION
WE AGREE WITH MR COLONY. THAT
THE FUNDING SHOULD GO FOR
OPERATING SUBSIDIES AND RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PRIMARILY.
.
THAT COULD BE DONE THROUGH A
RENTAL ASSISTANCE POOL THAT
COULD FUND A VARIETY OF MEASURES
DEPENDING ON THE LOCAL NEED.
WE DO THINK THAT THE FUNDING
SHOULD ALSO BE FOCUSED ON PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE THAT AND I HAVE SEEN
DRAMATIC.
DECREASES IN CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS WHEREAS IN OUR
STATE WE HAVE NOW FORTY TWO
PERCENT OF THE NATION'S
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS POPULATION
AND THAT.
SHARE INCREASES EVERY YEAR.
I'M AND THEN FINALLY I WOULD TO
SAY THAT.
AGAIN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FUNDING IS SUSTAINABLE.
AND THAT IT IS OF THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE COMMITTING
FUTURE ALLOCATIONS OF THE S. B.
TWO DOLLARS. AND THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT SOMETHING LIKE
RENTAL SYSTEMS COULD BE SO
STAINED OVER TIME.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR.
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SPEAKER.
JEFF STARTED YET AN ADVOCATE.
I'M HERE IS DOG FIGHT BECAUSE I
CAME HERE AS PART OF A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF HOUSING WANTING
TO SEE HOW I CAN EDUCATE BETTER
PEOPLE. DEALING WITH THE SP TWO
FUNDING. I'VE ATTENDED YOUR
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THE NO PLACE AT
HOME AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. YOU ARE
PROBLEMS IN PUBLIC INPUT YOU
NEED TO SEEK BETTER MEANS OF
PUBLIC INPUT LIKE HERE. YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR A NUMBER OF
YOUR HOUSING HERE MEANS THERE'S
VERY FEW OF US HERE RIGHT NOW.
JUST LIKE THERE'S VERY FEW OF
YOU HERE RIGHT NOW
TO I BELIEVE ALLEN WOULD THERE
IS A NUMBER OF STUDIES YOU AS
YOU SAY WITH BOTH THE.
SHALL WE SAY LIGHT RAIL LINES
AND THE OTHER THINGS IN LOS
ANGELES.
AS OF CENTER DEBATE YOU CAN TELL
YOU THAT OF THE UC SEE UP HERE
DID SOME STUDIES ON
TRANSPORTATION THIS LAST FALL
RIGHT HERE BUT TYPICALLY OF
THESE AREAS IRVINE THROUGH
IRVINE. AT OTHER YOU SEE
PROGRAMS LOOK UNIT ASSESSING AND
EVALUATING THINGS THINGS.
THE A NEW EXPOSITION CORN OR IS
IT DOING EXACTLY THAT GREETING
THAT SITUATION BUT TO HEAR
TONIGHT. I'M HOPING THAT YOU
GUYS ARE GONNA DO BETTER AT
SHOWING US HOW WE IS YOU TALK
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
PROGRAMS. HOW WE CAN DO BETTER
HOPING YOU GET THAT MESSAGE OUT?
NOW THE OTHER SIDE I AM ALSO
HERE WHERE I CAN BE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR KARA TWO PLUS
MILLION PEOPLE TO GET THAT
MESSAGE OUT. I MOSTLY HERE OWLS
ANOTHER GROUP DESCRIBE VARIOUS
UP AND DOWN THIS STATE SO HELP
ME GET THAT MESSAGE OUT OF WHAT
YOU NEED. AT THE SAME TIME
LOCALLY I CAN HEAR I WILL
TONIGHT AT SIX THIRTY REPORT TO
SACRAMENTO HOUSING REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY OF WHAT I HEAR YOU DOING.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE WAS SAID FOR
THE USE THAT THE STAKE HOLDERS
MEETING. THAT IS PROBABLY A YEAR
AWAY BEFORE ANYTHING IS MUCH
GOING TO WORK OUT.
FOR THIS.
AS YOU CAN ALSO SAY THE NEED IS
INCREDIBLY WAY BEHIND THE EIGHT
BALL SO PLEASE.
I WORK WITH YOUR BUT PLEASE
LET'S SEE WHAT MORE WE CAN
FIGURE OUT AND KNOW THAT A LOT
OF THINGS.
ARE NOT REAL EFFICIENT BUT THE
NEED IS GREAT AND.
JUST LIKE OF ITS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
YOU GOT ONE WAY OF DOING IT JUST
LIKE YOU GOT PEOPLE THAT A BIT
OUT THERE SEVEN EIGHT YEARS.
JUST LIKE YOU'VE GOTTEN THE LAST
YEAR WERE VIEW OF DRAMATICALLY
DOUBLED OR TRIPLED OR MORE.
THE HOMELESS POPULATION SO IT
NEEDS TO BE WILL LESS THAN FIVE
YEARS THAT THINGS IN TWO YEARS
WORKING THERE SPEAK EXISTING
PROGRAMS. LIKE OTHER THINGS YOU
NEED TO REFUND.
JUST LIKE YOU SUGGESTED THE
NUMBER S. S. I ALSO WORKING JUST
LIKE WITH YOUR YOU KNOW TWO FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE. ARE EXISTING AT
LESS THAN A THOUSAND AND WHEN
YOU HAVE. JUST SIMPLY FOR
HOUSING.
A THOUSAND AND YOU AFTER THREE
TIMES THAT INCOME.
THAT WHOLE COMMUNITY.
YOU KNOW IS LESS THAN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIKE SPEAKER.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT CULP
ANOTHER BLOCK THEIR SHOCK A A
MAP YOU OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ALEC
I THINK.
CENTER CARRABELLE AND THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIPPER CHAIR IN
THIS COMMITTEE WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HERE WE NEED
MORE HOUSING BEING BUILT.
AN EXPLORER OUTCLASSED HAWKINS
IF NOT DEAD.
BECAUSE ANY FOOD ONE THE
LEADERS.
WHERE DO NOT A BALLOT MEASURE
PERET TWENTY EIGHTEEN?
IN NOVEMBER.
AND AS FAR AS THAT RENT CONTROL
JUST BECAUSE THE VIXEN LAVA
FIGURES ARE GOING TO TRY TO GET
THAT.
ON THE BALLOT MEASURE THEIR
FAITH INCLUDING SACRAMENTO THANK
YOU.
HUMAN.
THE CHAIR I'M CHRIS MY WITH
HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
WANNA ECHO SHARON'S COMMENTS
EARLIER AROUND
THE YEAR ONE FUNDS FOR AS WE TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS TO TO
HAVE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS AND.
PHILIP FLEXIBLE SOLUTIONS AROUND
RENTAL SUBSIDIES AND OPERATING
SUBSIDIES.
AS WELL AS.
YOU KNOW JURISDICTIONS THAT
WILL LOOK AT YOUR TWO THROUGH
FIVE FUNDS IN FUTURE INVESTMENTS
TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AS WELL.
ALSO WANT TO.
.
ADVOCATE FOR.
YOU KNOW A ROBUST INVESTMENT
INTO A CD TO IMPLEMENT THE
PACKAGE AND THE HOUSING PACKAGE
THAT WAS. MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND AS WELL AS SUPPORT FOR YOUR.
BUDGET REQUEST FOR ONE BILLION
DOLLARS HALF THAT GOING TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND HAVE TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS I THINK
THOSE ARE VERY CRUCIAL
INVESTMENTS FOR THE STATE TO
MAKE. THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU.
AT THIS TIME PUBLIC COMMENT IS
CLOSE LET ME ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF AND IF YOU HAVE FINAL COMMENT
YOU LIKE TO MAKE.
NOW SEE NOT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR ENGAGING IN
TODAY'S.
HEARING OPTICALLY ALL OF THE UP
PANELS.
WE OBVIOUSLY STILL HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS OF THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THAT CRISIS.
EXPERIENCE BY TENETS OF BUT TO
LOOK FOR TO NETWORK TOGETHER
THERE WITH THAT OF THIS MEETING
IS NOW ADJOURNED